if we could just get back to the medical
students and residents and teach them
that pregnancy is a normal function of
the body very much like digestion or
breathing It's A Primitive brain
functions it's instinctual you don't
have to think about it baby's going to
grow inside of you whether you think
about it or not you're going to digest
your food when you think about it or not
and you're going to breathe without
having to think about it thank God but
when something goes wrong with your
breathing they have an Hazmat attack or
you get colitis you need a doctor when
you're pregnant you don't need a doctor
unless you start to develop a problem
midwives are excellent in normal
birthing therefore being experts in
normal birthing they can immediately
recognize when something isn't normal
when something isn't normal they want
the best for their client that's when
you call a consultant that's when the
collaboration between systems Works
beautifully that way but that loses
control of the of the whole process and
the financial control and stuff the
people that are running our Health Care
system are happy as a clam they think
it's doing fine I don't think the
doctors and nurses that are working in
it think it's doing fine I don't think
the women that are being cared for in it
think it's doing fine you know we're all
just cogs in the hamster wheel we can't
necessarily Advocate change it's going
to take the women of the country
demanding things from their doctors
you're going to ask their doctor's
questions
[Music]
that was Dr Stuart fishbein a practicing
obstetrician since 1986. he supports
vbac and specializes in community-based
natural breach and twin birthing and is
a strong believer in the Midwifery model
of care and the right of a woman to True
informed consent and refusal in the
birth process Dr Stu has published a
book called Fearless pregnancy wisdom
and reassurance from a doctor a midwife
and a mom and three peer-reviewed papers
on home and breach birthing he travels
around the country and internationally
teaching the disappearing art of breach
delivery and his podcast birthing
instincts is helping women all over the
world reclaim their power in pregnancy
birth and postpartum this episode is
packed with information on making
informed choices and ensuring bodily
autonomy in the birthing process we
cover the problems happening in our
standard medical birthing model the
Cascade of interventions that happens in
the hospital setting explaining the pros
and cons to these routines the
prevalence of personal bias in
scientific papers and poorly controlled
research red flags when choosing a
practitioner Dr Sue's story and how we
went from practicing obstetrics in the
hospital to assisting midwives at home
with breach and twin deliveries if birth
is a medical problem or a normal natural
function of the human female body and
more it goes without saying that Dr Stu
and I have something in common we are
both incredibly passionate about the
power and sacredness of birth so we had
so much fun in this conversation and
could have gone on for hours more than
we already did I hope you enjoy our
conversation welcome to the Ellen Fisher
podcast let's get started
okay you guys Mother's Day is right
around the corner so you do not want to
miss out on this limited edition Golden
Glow Body Trio by osia for Mother's Day
it's a three-piece glow boosting and
skin smoothing body set that's the
perfect gift for all skin types and
would make an incredible Mother's Day
gift either to yourself or a mother
figure in your life female founded and
family operated since 1996 osia is clean
vegan cruelty free seaweed-based skin
and body care inspired by the story of
their Founder's grandmother who was a
great believer in the power of the sea
this Trio comes with a plant-based body
brush which preps the skin for optimal
moisture by sweeping away dead skin
cells the undaria algae body oil which
is clinically proven to instantly
improve skin elasticity and deliver deep
moisturization and the anti-aging body
bomb which is a new favorite of mine it
smells incredible and combines the
lasting hydration of a lotion with the
anti-aging benefits of a serum I make
using OCS products of ritual and daily
self-care practice because their natural
skin care line is so effective and
improves the health of my skin so don't
miss out on this deal for a limited time
to get 10 percent off with the code
Ellen glow I hope you enjoy this special
gift thank you Dr Sue for being here
I've been very much looking forward to
this conversation on my podcast I've had
a couple episodes about birth but none
specifically on the topics that we're
going to cover today on issues within
our medical model that we have Today
medical system so thanks for being here
I'm so glad you made it out here in
person
how could I resist the invitation and
thank you for your hospitality it's been
great for people who are new to you just
learning who you are and also just for
me I'd love to hear your story how you
came to be in the position of going
through medical school being an
obstetrician in the hospital to
delivering and helping assist twin and
breach bursts at home with midwives okay
it wasn't a sliding door moment this was
something that evolved over many many
years and I probably would have to take
you all the way back to my childhood
where I was this sort of inquisitive
person that was always ask why
why and the parent my parents eventually
would say because I said so that sort of
thing and that never sat well with me
and so that same characteristic carried
with me through high school and into
college and then
I never really wanted to be a doctor
that wasn't really my goal I didn't
really know what I wanted to do I went
to college because that's the train that
everybody was on
back in the 70s I mean you graduated
high school you go to college while I
was in college a lot of my friends were
going pre-med and I said well I can do
what they're doing and I was a biology
major anyway so I said okay I'll go to
med school and that made my mom Jewish
Mom very happy that her son was going to
go to medical school and I got into
medical school at the University of
Minnesota
and I was trained in the same way that
everybody is still trained today it's
very academic it's very medicalized the
interesting thing about medical school
is that it's not competitive because
once you're in they do everything they
can to keep you in so it was a there was
a spirit of camaraderie with other
doctors and even though at this point in
my career I I look on other doctors
sometimes with disdain I still have
respect for the fact that they went
through trial by fire to go to medical
school and residency it's not an easy
thing to do
in your third year of medical school you
have to make a decision and you're
certainly not ready to make that
decision and that decision is what am I
going to do for the rest of my life
because you have to pick a specialty
because you have to start applying to
residency programs in that specialty and
what do you really know as a third year
medical student
so the reason I picked obstetrics for my
residency program application was purely
by chance I had just come off something
called Hematology Oncology rotation
where I had actually been working with
with kids in Pediatrics and had some
kids with fungal infections of their
brain with leukemia and they're on
chemotherapy it was very sad and tragic
and then my next rotation was Obstetrics
and instead of being up at three in the
morning dealing with a kid having a
seizure I'm up at three in the morning
catching a baby so that's sort of where
I went and in life in general
I don't have that many moments where you
can say that if I would have gone left
my life would have been completely
different
but this is one of them it's called the
match and it happens in your fourth year
of medical school probably the third
week in March where you've been applying
to residency programs they have been
interviewing you they all rank each
other and then it goes into a computer
and it comes out and you get an envelope
and pretty much across the country on
the same day at the same hour every
fourth year medical student opens the
envelope and it tells them where they're
going to be spending their next three
four five years depending on what
specialty they want it to go into and I
matched in Southern California at
Cedars-Sinai hospital and that changed
everything
I never expected to stay in California
but I went through the residency program
at Cedar Sinai and I thought I knew
everything you know and we were all
thought we were hot shot residents I the
fourth year I was the administrative
chief resident and I did everything that
I was taught medically I thought that
pregnancy was a medical disease that
needed to be treated and at any moment
things could go wrong because this is
the model by which you're you're you're
trained and once you're indoctrinated
into something it's really hard to get
out of it so I came out of residency
program in 1986 and for the first 10
years in practice I was that medicalized
doctor that we all talk about and
sometimes we mock a little bit the
person that's wearing the full hazmat
suit that has the woman up in stirrups
and starts washing off her bottom with
Betadine and catches the baby
immediately and takes the clamp puts it
immediately on the cord and maybe hands
the scissors to the dad and lets the dad
cut the cord shows the baby to the
mother and then walks the baby across
the room and sets it down in the war
room and we thought that we were doing
the right thing in medical school when I
did my OB rotation we cut episiotomies
on every single woman wow didn't matter
if it was her second baby third baby
fifth baby first baby did they ever
explain why
which is that's the way it's done and as
a third year medical student who are you
going to question
so that became routine another thing
that was routine back in the 80s because
we were maybe explain what an episiotomy
is for anybody who's listening yeah well
the perineum is the area of skin between
your vagina and your anus
all right and sometimes it tears
so there's this thinking that rather
than having a tear which can be ragged
and harder to sow is to cut with a
scissors a straight little line through
the skin and probably some of the muscle
to avoid it actually from tearing all
the way into the rectum
but this is an old-fashioned way of
thinking and all you need to do is if
you know how to deliver a baby and you
let a woman be in the position that she
wants to be in and you don't force them
to push when they're not ready to push
that the likelihood of getting a bad
tear is very very small and then we did
silly things like we gave women shots of
medicine to dry up their milk so that
they wouldn't get engorged and they
could you then use formula and this was
standardized because we we fell under
the spell of the even then back then
everybody knows now but we fell under
the spell of the pharmaceutical industry
they wind and dined us they took us to
Laker games they you know then finally
eventually they passed a rule or a law
that said they can maybe give us a
chicken sandwich but they can't really
whine and diet us anymore but it's still
very influential and when I look back at
my residency program I can see how it
everything that we did was influenced by
somebody who really wasn't doing the
work it was some higher up administrator
cubicle worker bureaucrat risk manager
that sort of thing but back then for
those first 10 years I was very
medicalized
what changed me was the idea that early
in my practice back in 87 or 88 I was
approached by some midwives locally and
asked to take their transports and that
means a woman who's at home who you know
is tired or could be an emergency but
rarely is an emergency most of the time
it's just their labors petered out or
they're tired and they need to come in
and often they'll get an epidural and
then some pitocin and then they'll have
a vaginal delivery or they needed a
vacuum or something like that so I said
sure and I didn't say sure because I
thought home birth and Midwifery was a
good idea I thought it was stupid
because that's the way I was trained I
said sure because I wanted to make money
because the way you practiced back in
those days was you built a practice from
scratch you came out you may have gotten
a job with a group but you were expected
to hustle and build your practice so I
covered free clinics I covered emergency
rooms I assisted people in surgery I
took call for other doctors who wanted
to take less call and slowly but surely
built my practice nowadays when a doctor
comes out of residency it's almost a
certainty that the just get a job
working as a corporate physician for a
big HMO or a big hospital complex and
there's a lot of problems with that and
maybe we'll get down to the ethics of
that later
so
during those times where those women
were in a hospital after they got their
epidural there'd be time where I'd be
sitting with a midwife in the lounge and
we'd be hanging out and I started to
hear a whole different way of doing
things and I realized that their clients
were not
hippies so to speak they were actually
in Los Angeles they were Hollywood
people professional people doctors
lawyers very well educated and actually
probably more well educated than my own
clients because the midwives and the
model they practice they spend an hour
doing a prenatal and in those days if
they if I spent 10 minutes that was a
long time for a prenatal because we in
the medical model used to do volume and
they and midwives don't do volume so I
began to see a different way of doing
things and I slowly but surely began to
change and after 10 years I started a
collaborative Midwifery practice in the
hospital not Cedars because they didn't
allow midwives in those days so it was
out in Ventura County with two certified
nurse midwives and we started a
collaborative practice where
The Midwives did mostly the normal stuff
like they would do the well-woman exams
the pap smears the prenatal visits uh uh
they would catch the normal babies that
sort of thing and I would if somebody
had an abnormal pap smear I would do the
colposcopy I would do the biopsies I
would do surgery I would put forceps out
I would be the one that took care of the
breaches or twins if somebody needed a
cesarean uh that I would be the one that
would do that and it was a really great
model we had a seven percent C-section
rate
the next best group in the hospital same
cohort of women so we're not talking
about cherry-picked women here like
nowadays midwives cherry pick their
clients they can't take somebody with
preeclampsia they can't take a diabetic
they're not going to take twins
generally so but we took all comers and
and RC secretary was seven percent and
the next group was probably around 26
which still by today's standards is
pretty good but that's amazing but the
only difference being the model by which
we cared for the clients and um from the
moment we started doing that with the
collaborative practice the hospital and
the people that worked in the hospital
were never really accepting of us and
that's the problem and I've heard this
from other doctors around the country
who've tried the same sort of thing
eventually if you you know the old
Japanese proverb if you're the nail that
stands out what do you do you pound it
back in again so because we were doing
things differently we made other people
uncomfortable and rather than them
self-reflect and look at their own way
of practicing they made it harder and
harder for us to practice and eventually
they got to the point where they weren't
going to renew my privileges they took
away the midwives privileges they took
away vbac they took away V back is
vaginal birth after cesarean they took
away breach delivery and then they were
going to renew my privileges and so the
question was am I going to go to court
to fight to stay at a hospital that's
really hostile to me anyway or am I
going to go off and do something
different
and the people that really didn't like
us at the hospital were not just the OB
Department surprisingly the well I mean
not surprisingly the anesthesiologists
and the pediatricians were also made
very uncomfortable by our practice one
because most of our clients didn't want
an epidural so there's no money in that
there's no money in not doing something
right right and then the pediatricians
didn't like our our clients because
they were hesitant about hepatitis
vaccine or vitamin K or they wanted to
go home six hours after they gave birth
and that could have been at two in the
morning and no no pediatrician wanted to
come in
at two in the morning can I digress for
a second and tell this little story yeah
okay
so
pediatricians have to see every baby in
the hospital before they go home
everybody knows that okay but 30 years
ago wasn't that way okay pediatricians
didn't see babies in the hospital they
only saw babies in the hospital if the
nurses called them to do it otherwise if
you look at pictures from the 50s and
60s and 70s the babies are all in the
little bassinets lined up and the dad's
knocking on the glass going you know
that's my baby that's my baby yeah
um uh but the nurses took care of them
and that was it
but in the 80s maybe it was the 70s
maybe it's the 80s pediatric departments
began to realize that insurance
companies were paying for newborn exams
so a lot of these hospitals almost all
of them put in a policy
that said no baby can be discharged
without being seen by a pediatrician it
was a way to grab uncaptured Revenue
what happened then 10 15 years later was
managed care came in and said well yes
you can do whatever you want but we're
not paying for that
so the policy didn't go away but the
revenue went away so now the doctor's
policy came back to bite him in the ass
when a patient wants to go home at two
in the morning before they could have
just gone home but now they can't go
home because the doctor has to come in
but the doctor doesn't want to come in
for no money who would I don't blame
them
so get rid of the policy but what's a
policies in place you know how hard it
is you do I know I know you know how
hard it is to get rid of it
so that's sort of how I ended up leaving
the hospital because they sort of left
me
and what's funny about it is that I had
several women who were due after that
date where I was not going to be renewed
anymore and they came to me and they
said listen just deliver us at home
we'll do it at home because they knew
that my reputation was already that I
was backing midwives and that I was
already changing and I was already doing
breaches and Twins and all that thing
and I was still hesitant after 25 years
in practice I had still never been to a
home group wow so what was that like for
your first home well fortunately it was
the most beautiful thing
because it captured your heart I'm sure
it did no I was so lucky because the
first five 10 15 of them were all just
those perfect home births that everybody
loves I didn't have any I wasn't at that
point I wasn't doing some of the more
complicated stuff that I'm doing now
yeah and it was it was great I can't
imagine my life would have been
different had the first one been in
emergency transport with 9-1-1 that
would have been a whole different thing
right but those are really rare and
um and so and then the rest is history
then I just started doing that and I got
Bolder as time went by
and I got more well known in the
community and I was backing up all you
know pretty much a lot of The Midwives
in Southern California and I was
traveling from the Mexican border all
the way up to San Luis Obispo which is
like two three hundred miles either way
because I was the only OB
doing things and there's certain laws in
California
another thing we could talk about
um yeah yeah I actually was just gonna
see if we could unpack that because
someone I think it's helpful context
that in California the law as it stands
I mean you can explain it but um
basically it's a legal right for a
midwife to deliver help deliver uh twin
or breech birth without a physician
attending is that the exactly the right
one yeah every state has a slightly
different rules but that's a pretty
standard Rule and in some in States
certainly California they also have some
really
what I would call dumb rules again the
medical model thinks of pregnancy as an
illness and therefore they want to
control everything and so in controlling
everything they don't care that they've
caused chaos
it's it's it's funny it's there's a lot
of analogies about that I won't go into
one now but one of the rules they put in
place was that no woman can deliver at
home if she's before 37 weeks or after
42 weeks
first of all dating is is not a perfect
science
second of all
a baby that's 36 weeks and five days is
going to do just fine at home and if it
doesn't and it needs to be transferred
to the hospital
then they can transfer the baby to the
hospital it's not going to be an
emergency emergency transport and the
mother could at least have the birth
that she wanted
but
people in power they like setting
numbers they like having limits they
like working on an algorithm
human beings we're not algorithms and
not every Midwife I mean midwives are
trained in normal birthing they're
experts in it
so why can't they they let them go they
license them and then they tell them
here's how you're going to practice with
your license it's like wait a minute I
went why did I go through all this
training if you're going to tell me how
to practice for a devil's advocate
someone might be thinking well it's for
the safety of the mother and they're
looking at the research and deciding
what's best how would you reply reply to
that first of all safety is a Canard
safety is something that is in the eyes
of the beholder no what's what you
believe is safe somebody else may not
believe is safe is 100 safe
some people would say yes
some people would say no one in 100
means 99 of the time it's not going to
happen you can depends on how you
present the data so they it's often used
as a a club to get people to do what you
want them to do as a parent you say you
know well you don't because I've seen
your kids running around here and stuff
like that but you know many parents will
say uh you know you you can't do that
and they'll go why it's not safe but it
really is it really not safe or is it
just the parents don't want them doing
it so they use safety as a and that's
what goes on here too and by the way
ultimately and we're going to get
through this probably the whole theme as
we go along
is whose decision is it as to what
safety is
is it some academician is it some
Medical Board is it some lawyer or is it
the individual woman in her pregnancy
deciding what she feels safe with as you
know being a home birth mom yourself is
that you felt safer far safer being at
home yeah another woman would feel far
safer being in the hospital yeah both of
those are legitimate choices we
shouldn't be
limiting them
based on safety especially since the
hospital model
it's supposed to be the Bastion of
safety isn't doing very well yeah and
we're going to get into all that and yes
like the theme being informed consent
and for every woman and couple to be
able to make their own informed choices
based on what makes the most sense to
them and the information that's given to
them and I love seeing all the things
that you're sharing online about how
important it is that we're really given
all the information because so much of
what you talk about is how in the
hospital we're really not getting
everything we need to know about all the
decisions that are being made in the
hospital
[Music]
I just launched a birth course called
the empowered pregnancy and birth that
I've worked so hard on these last months
and I've never been more proud of
something I've created this course is
filled with everything I wish I was told
before I came pregnant with my first
child over a decade ago to have an
easier quicker labor and even a
pleasurable birth experience I created
the course with my sister Hannah McNeely
and we have some incredible contributors
in this course including Dr Gemma Newman
who collaborated with us on plant
forward prenatal nourishment she's an MD
who's a senior partner at a family
medical practice that has worked in many
Specialties including obstetrics
Gynecology and Pediatrics we have Haley
Callahan a donor certified Doula who
collaborated with us on having an
empowered birth for those choosing a
hospital setting we also have an
incredible yoga instructor Michelle
Minch with prenatal yoga classes in
birth meditation and finally Heather
McCain on the Mind change method and how
to rewire your brain for a more
pleasurable and gentle birth experience
which is one of the most powerful parts
of the course in my opinion because
something like Hypno birthing for
example can be really helpful for a lot
of women but for many women like myself
you can say all the positive mantras you
want out loud and envision the birth you
desire but if your subconscious believes
otherwise and tells you uh-uh that's not
what birth feels like I know what the
movie showed me it feels like I know
what my mom and friends say it feels
like I know what my past birth
experiences even felt like then it's not
going to get you very far that's why we
have to rewire our brain and change not
only the conscious mind but also the
subconscious mind and Heather someone
who's helped so many women like myself
achieve the birthday desire shows you in
this course how to do that this course
is centered around becoming empowered
and making informed choices optimal
pregnancy nourishment giving birth where
you feel safest getting back to birthing
wisdom and my favorite part how to have
an easy quick and pleasurable birth
experience it's filled with how to
prepare your mind and body for
conception creating a birth plan that's
right for you we also go into nutrients
of focus healthy foods to embrace and
supporting your body through movement
how to get baby in the optimal position
for birth and the secrets to avoid
tearing how to have an easier labor
guaranteed and the information that made
my last three labors significantly more
pleasurable gentle quick and easy than
my first two we include everything you
need to know postpartum breastfeeding
and more and there's even a lesson for
your partner if you have one in how they
can best support mama in pregnancy labor
birth and postpartum so you can get
access to the course at ellenfischer.com
or click the link in the show notes and
description box just click the link to
learn more about the course I've never
been more proud and excited about
something I've created birth is
life-changing and I'm really passionate
about sharing all that birth can be
gentle peaceful easy and even
pleasurable
okay so firstly going back to the the
laws in California in other states to be
clear for people listening like here in
Hawaii midwives can deliver breach and
twin bursts at home without a physician
attending at what point did the medical
school stop teaching Obstetricians how
to deliver breach and delivers at the
hospital yeah that's that's fairly easy
it was it was people always want to say
it was in the year 2000 when the paper
called the term breach Trail came out
but it was already falling out of
disfavor before that
and it's almost as if those people in
Academia who just favored breach kind of
said you know what we need we needed a
paper that's going to support our
position and then suddenly a paper comes
out that supports their position and
immediately is adopted and it's really
rare for a paper to come out to change
clinical practice that quickly because
there are papers that come out that
support breach delivery and there's
almost every paper since the 2000 term
breach trial has been supportive
properly selected term for each delivery
but those are completely ignored or very
slow to adopt so what happens is the the
powers that be and I'm not sure exactly
who those people are they get something
in their head that this is the way we
want to practice and then Academia will
respond to that with support for that
position so again this is off topic a
little bit but science is completely
corrupted these days you can't trust
anything that you read even in academic
journals that you we've seen that in the
last two years where there's been
fraudulent articles point that have had
to be retracted in in reputable journals
like the New England Journal of Medicine
or the landsat
um and then again you have to look at
who's
sponsoring the the research a lot of
times and you know you'll find out it's
somebody who's benefiting from the
determination of the research itself and
then who and then who's who's
financially supporting the journal
actually I don't think it's off topic at
all
because those papers that are deciding
the rules that are going forward like
you said in the hospitals and this is
why they're doing these procedures in
these standards and those types of
routine things so it's absolutely
important into the conversation because
people might think well maybe the reason
that we stopped doing vaginal breach
deliveries is because it's unsafe and
the outcomes are you know really poor
most of the time and that might be what
someone thinks but what do you think
about it
well that is what that is what's taught
and that's why the residency programs
shortly after that paper came out
immediately stopped training and to this
point there's very very few residency
programs in any Western Country that's
still teaching breach delivery there are
a few centers around the world that do
it but very very rare that it's taught
um
because part of the part of the bigger
picture is that we are taught in medical
school residency that that pregnancy is
an illness or a disease and we need to
fear it and when doctors are trained in
a fear-based world
that's all they know and then when they
go out and practice they project their
own fears and anxieties onto the women
they're caring for and thus the American
popular population is more fearful than
say a population that that isn't
influenced by media you could talk about
the Amish women or you could talk about
women from third world countries they
may actually even know somebody in their
Community who died in childbirth and
they have less anxiety about being
pregnant as a matter of fact it's a life
event for them they they look forward to
it with with great joy whereas so many
people in our country look for it as a
difficult bridge to cross that that the
idea of a C-section scheduled at 39
weeks is a blessing for them
but they all but that's because they're
only given
they're given skewed informed consent
they're not given true information and
that's that's to me is one of the
biggest problems is that there's so many
things about informed consent
that I'm missing but one of the biggest
problems with it is the system itself
doesn't allow for the time and the
process to give true informed consent so
they give skew informed consent and
especially with the corporate
corporatization of Medicine
doctors who want to give true informed
consent
are basically told they can't do that
one you don't have time to do that and
if you do that you're going to get fired
so
where we go with this is that we get you
know we can't solve the problem of
informed consent until we fix or change
the system which it all sits in and
right now that I I see that as a very
difficult task but that's sort of what
happened is that is that a paper comes
out it meets the meets the requirements
that people want and then they just they
just do it the same thing happened with
the arrived trial I don't know if you
know about that that's a one where when
this induce all women at 39 weeks wow
can you imagine well yeah and it's being
it's being used in a lot of places
around the country are in
you know giving that as evidence that
women should be induced to 39 weeks
there's so much wrong with that paper
yeah but no one looks deeply into it
when it fits the model by which they
want to care for people it makes their
it makes them
people that run the medical system makes
their job easier yeah because so much of
it is based like you said on fear fear
of being sued even so they want to cover
all their tracks cover their bases look
I did this I did this I did this you
can't sue me I tried everything so it's
like an easier model for for the
position than it is for what's best for
the patient yeah and this gets me to
where one of the things that I talk
about all the time when I do my breach
seminars is that in the medical model if
you look at a research paper or if you
look at
um
policies of a hospital there's only
really one thing that matters
and that's a live baby in the bassinet
how the baby gets there
the mother's Journey
the mother's future babies future
pregnancies future Journeys isn't
relevant
and I can tell you a great example of
that whenever I see a breaching consult
they'll come in at 37 38 39 weeks and
they their doctor has given them no
choices but to have a cesarean
so they'll they'll come in to see me and
one of the questions I'll ask them and I
always 100 have gotten the same answer
is did your doctor ever ask you if you
want more children
and the answer is universally no
because all that doctor's thinking about
is that baby in the bassinet and I don't
know how to do breach delivery so I need
to talk you into having a cesarean
section which may may slightly decrease
the risks just a little bit to that
original that baby especially if you're
not really skilled or you don't pick
your clients properly
but any any savings of risk that you
give with that baby that you got with
that baby will be
transmitted to all of your future babies
and the mother herself because now she
has the scarred uterus issue not to
mention the risk of the C-section itself
because remember all that matters is
the Baby Alive baby
yes yes and I think what you said is
fascinating too about the fear of the
doctor being projected onto the mother
is totally valid our minds are so
powerful so if you go into labor having
all this fear that might have been
subconsciously put on to you throughout
your pregnancy not just by your doctor
but by Society at large and the things
we see in movies that that affects how
your labor is and I can just personally
attest to all of my home births and my
midwives that their steady calm and
Trust of birth was pivotal for me and my
trust of birth too and how they trust my
body trust me trust the experience that
helps so much in your labor experience
too yeah well I mean this gets back to
the basic of being a mammal this is not
something that a lot of people think
about but it's really basic think about
how mammals give birth when a mammal is
ready to go into labor where does she go
she goes off to a quiet place who goes
with her nobody if she's hungry she eats
if she's thirsty she drinks if she's
uncomfortable she moves
and if she's interrupted or if there's a
forest fire or a predator approaching or
little kids run into the room when your
dog is in labor they put out adrenaline
adrenaline stops the labor the mammal
gets up
runs away fight or flight they're not
going to fight they're going to flight
and only when it's safe will labor
return This Way nature ensures the best
chance of survival
so when from the moment a woman walks
into her obstetrician's office at 10
weeks pregnant
they're being
seated
with fear-based information not only are
you bathing your baby in fear hormones
the entire pregnancy
but the idea that it's not going to be
affecting your labor is naive but yet my
colleagues don't don't know that they
don't understand that Nature's design is
nearly perfect
now there are problems with it and of
course that's when Obstetricians are
very valuable and we're really good at
that but that's maybe 10 15 of
pregnancies the other 85 or 90 don't
need that sort of intervention
and when you have that that sense that
nature knows what it's doing and if you
interfere with Nature's design there's
going to be Ripple effects Downstream
they may be small they may be they may
be immediate they may be much later in
time like your wonderful podcast about
the microbiome I mean I mean we could go
off on that tangent too
um
how we start off
is something that's really important but
if you do a C-section scheduled at 39
weeks and the baby goes over to the
warmer and then Mom gets to hold the
baby for two minutes before the baby
goes off to the nursery that's You're
Breaking the Chain of how nature
designed labor to go there's a there's a
beautiful Symphony going on between
mother and her baby for all the nine
months and it doesn't just end when
labor starts it actually gets more
intense you get the French horns and the
violins and the cellos all playing at
once when labor starts it's really
spectacular I got a whole thing about
epidurals and that sort of thing too
maybe we'll talk about that I definitely
want to talk about okay all right when a
baby is born it it's mostly sterile and
it needs to be colonized with the
bacteria that nature designed and those
are the bacteria on moms in mom's vagina
on her mom's skin
that's what's supposed to happen and in
every other again I get back to the
mammalian birth is that no other mammal
ever has its baby taken away from it
nobody rushes in to cut the cord on any
other mammal the idea that you you know
oh you will we'll do delayed core
clamping for one minute there's another
one of those perfect number things
whenever they come out with a number
like that like 42 weeks or one minute or
six feet apart that sort of stuff you
know that that's it's crap
um no and and you know try taking a baby
a baby monkey away from its mother
yeah seriously it's not gonna happen I
cannot even imagine if my bursts like I
I give birth and then someone takes my
baby away from me and goes to the other
side of the room and they're doing their
tests and I mean I know multiple women
who that has been their experience and I
know that's just how you just depicted
the beginning stages of your career your
career too in the hospital we need to
get back to thinking that you know that
nature has a good design what we do to
the human female from the moment you get
in your car
to go to the hospital for your birth and
it may be your best choice for you and
I'm not
I don't want your viewers to think that
that I'm bashing Hospital Birthing right
I'm not I'm bashing the system that runs
Hospital yeah but the moment you get in
a car to the moment you put your baby in
the car seat to drive home
pretty much everything that's done to
you is antithetical to Nature's design
you're asked to come into the hospital
you're asked to change into a hospital
gown
is a very big thing
people don't think well what's wrong
with that well what does a hospital gun
signify
signifies that you're a patient that
you're sick that you're sick
why can't you wear your own pajamas why
can't you wear nothing yeah okay have
you ever seen the Jim Gaffigan comedy
concert about having four home births
I've probably yes because I love Jim
Gaffney yeah it reminds me of the
segment that he did where he's he says
something about how giving birth at a
hospital and someone else replies and
says oh we were gonna do that but we
wanted our baby to live and then later
he brings it it's so good and then later
he brings up what you didn't want to
give birth at a hospital gown that
somebody died in yesterday
yeah no he's great and he's he's at what
six seven homers I don't know now at the
time it was four I think yeah he had he
had that show on for a while by the way
his wife that was in that show was one
of our clients oh no way not his real
wife his TV one oh oh got it yeah no not
his real life anyway sorry for that
tangent just made me think of that about
like I wouldn't want to be in a hospital
gown no so they make it a hospital they
make you pee in a cup
why I mean again it's a very simple
thing well they have to check while
you're in for protein well why
why your prep your blood pressure is
normal you're not complaining of any
painful peeing or urination you you know
it's a billable charge that's why if you
really want to think about it foreign
and it's because they're algorithmic if
if a woman has an issue with their blood
pressure or feels funny when she's
peeing yes check her urine but why does
every single person need to have a urine
checked and why does every single person
need to have their blood drawn
well we have to have we have to know
what our hemoglobin is well why we don't
know that at home
and our moms do fine yeah well we have
to have a blood clot in the lab in case
she needs to be transfused first of all
what's the chance of that second of all
what do you do if somebody rolls into
the ER with a gunshot wound yeah they
don't have a clot they they give them O
negative or they they cross them really
quickly so the likelihood but again it's
something they can build for is that
really the only reason or is it also
because of research that is telling that
this would be better give better
outcomes I don't think it's because of
research but even if there was research
that said that I don't trust the
research because again you have to look
at what the motivation is behind the
research
I would say this is a general tenant if
if something goes against what your gut
is telling you
it's probably wrong most of the time and
that seems to apply now maybe I just
have a sixth sense when it comes to
obstetrical stuff but I think that I've
expanded this into the common sense of
my own life in general and you hear a
story that just doesn't sound right and
then you find out two days later that it
was not real fake story so then they
then they strap you to a monitor they
limit your movement all right you've got
to be monitored well why I haven't been
monitored for nine months
well I don't have to monitor it now well
something might go wrong again that's
their philosophy the philosophy of how
something might go wrong uh and so once
when you couch everything you do in the
philosophy of something might go wrong
you never live in the world of well what
if it goes right
right because you're interfering in the
ability for things to go right then
you you know no mammal if your dog was
in labor you would never take away its
food or water
woman comes in the hospital she's lucky
if she'd get a popsicle
all right you're going to be in labor
for 16 hours and you're given a popsicle
okay think about that I mean well what
and the reasoning was well you might
aspirate and then if you needed an
anesthesia anesthetic that would be a
problem for the anesthesiologist it's
like preparing for the worst right so if
that happens one in a hundred thousand
times I just made up that number yeah
yeah that means 99 999 women are not
given a choice to eat
because they don't because it's whose
risk is it and I think anyone listening
who might be thinking well a specific
intervention saved my life or my baby's
life and
aled and so important and this is the
new the Nuance Nuance is such an
important word in this conversation but
I think it's also important for people
to realize that at what cost for all
those other ones where we or they
intervened when they didn't need to at
what cost is there like what are we not
getting as a result of doing those
interventions yeah I mean and again
we're talking about routine things here
now I mean again because the model does
not allow for individualization of care
because when you come to the hospital
you're being taken care of pretty much
by strangers
again do you feel safer take being taken
care of by someone you know your Midwife
of nine months or a stranger and I said
well my doctor will be there well your
doctor's in a call group of six people
so he's got a one in six chance of being
on and your doctor won't be there until
you're probably ready to push so you're
going to be taken care of by nurses and
nurses may be lovely and you may after a
few hours get to really love your nurse
but then guess what happens seven
o'clock in the morning or in the evening
rolls around and guess what change of
shift and so now you end up with another
stranger
are you does Amanda feel safe when
they're surrounded by strangers no again
we're talking about everything that they
do right you they you have to ring for a
nurse to be able to go to the bathroom
because you're strapped out you're
strapped down right are hospitals
starting to do it differently now though
like because the example you gave from
back at the beginning of your career
when you talked about the formula
feeding stopping the the flow of milk to
formula feed that doesn't seem to be a
thing anymore that's gone so has there
been progress since the beginning of
your career what do you think about it
yeah it's but you know what I mean
glaciers grow and recede at a certain
rate yeah yeah it needs to go fast
enough not fast enough in other words
that's right for sure it's not fast
enough for me
um and it's not fast enough for the
women that are being mistreated every
single day
and again this is an important point and
I know that I think some of your other
guests have made this point it's not
that the individual physician ever wants
anything to go wrong right for their or
their patient
um the nurse they don't they want to do
the best they can it's the system I'll
say it over and over again throughout
this interview it's the system that's
completely flawed
and and you can tell that because we
went from a C-section rate
50 years ago of five percent
to a C-section right now in the United
States of over 30 percent
that's a sick that's a 500 percent
increase in the cesarean section rate
and has the outcomes gotten any better
since then that's the thing that is the
thing cerebral palsy neonatal morbidity
and neonatal death are not any better
and maternal morbidity is probably
slightly higher all right in in the last
50 years we're not talking about 100
years ago these are just U.S staff yeah
U.S stats but but it's very similar in
Western countries it's all the same in
Western countries that that the
C-section rate has risen without any
commensurate benefit
um in neonatal outcomes
look at that right don't some of the
European countries include more
Midwifery model care within the hospital
some do and some are worse by far worse
than us oh yeah yeah I mean the
Netherlands England they seem to have a
fairly good model where a larger
percentage of women are having home
birth as a matter of fact it might be
even encouraged in women who are
multiparous which means they've already
had at least one vaginal delivery
um but there are other countries
especially in the more the Eastern
European block and stuff like that that
some countries midwifery's illegal home
birth is illegal I was speaking to a
group in Armenia last year and on zoom
and they have a 70 C-section rate and
Midwifery is illegal that's crazy I know
yeah
I think it really it really comes down
back to the trust of the woman and the
of our bodies and how little trust we
have we think of it as an illness like
birth as this illness sickness things
where do you go when you go to the
hospital you're going there because
you're sick or you're ill and you need
help in some way and it's just assumed
all growing up that's what I thought
growing up you go to the hospital and
you when you're about to give birth
because almost like it's an illness yeah
I'll give you a good example of that um
first of all midwives don't look at
Birth as an illness they look at it as
Wellness they trust it and they accept a
degree of uncertainty the medical model
doesn't trust it and say they accept no
uncertainty and in the process then they
intervene and their interventions cause
a lot of problems but their intervention
problems are are okay not intervening
problems are their fault why do you
think that is like that's just the way
they're trained and I'll give you a good
example of that I've been practicing now
36 years in private practice
up until about three years ago when I
took a history of a new person that came
into my practice you asked for chief
complaint you ask for allergies and meds
you ask about past medical history past
surgical history family history review
of systems that's sort of how you take a
history
when I got to past medical history I
would look I would always look at the
woman I go so do you have any other
medical problems which is a classic
question we asked until one day one
woman looked at me and she goes what's
the first one
and I thought for a second do you have
any other medical problems oh
see you you were even baffled yeah yeah
um that's because I'm assuming that your
pregnancy is a medical problem because
you're seeing me for your pregnancy I'm
a doctor
I don't wear white coat but wearing a
white coat if you're going to the doctor
there must be a problem and when you
based everything
in that ideology
then you can see how we've gotten to
where we've gotten now if we could just
get back to the medical students and
residents and teach them
that pregnancy is a normal function of
the body very much like digestion or
breathing It's A Primitive brain
functions it's instinctual you don't
have to think about it when you're
you're gonna baby's gonna grow inside of
you whether you think about it or not
you're going to digest your food whether
you think about it or not and you're
going to breathe without having to think
about it thank God because otherwise a
lot of people would stop breathing and
drop dead but
um when something goes wrong with your
breathing they have an Hazmat attack or
you get colitis you need a doctor when
you're pregnant you don't need a doctor
unless you start to develop a problem
midwives are excellent in normal
birthing therefore being experts in
normal birthing they can immediately
recognize when something isn't normal
it's like you know where I'm staying in
your
condo you've been in this condo a
thousand times I came in yesterday like
you're Ohana excuse me I don't want to
call him yeah it's an Ohana and I just
want people to understand that I bad
Stuart bad Stewart no no
um if I came in and that plant wasn't
where it belonged I wouldn't know that
but you would yeah I would not because
you're an expert in your Ohana and I'm
not
so the same sort of thing midwives are
experts in normal when something isn't
normal they don't want to they don't
they want the best for their clients
they're gonna they're gonna that's when
you call a consultant that's when the
the collaboration between systems Works
beautifully that way
but that loses control of the of the
whole process and the financial control
and stuff then and the people that are
running our Health Care system are are
happy as a clam they think it's doing
fine I don't think the doctors and
nurses that are working in it think it's
doing fine I don't think the women that
are being cared for in it think it's
doing fine
but you know we're all just cogs and you
know in the hamster wheel we can't
necessarily Advocate change it's going
to take the women of the country
demanding things from their doctors
you're going to ask their doctors
questions and if their doctor uses terms
like well it's risky then you have to
confront your doctor in a very pleasant
way and say well how risky is it
and say well it's very risky and then
you say could you give me some numbers
and I will almost guarantee your
listeners that they won't know wow
because they're just regurgitating
information that they were taught in
residency program by the same fear-based
people that are running the programs now
the idea that that academicians are
running my profession into the grave
doesn't occur to them and I'll explain
that because what makes an obstetrician
unique it's to be able to do something
that no other
profession can do a heart surgeon is
unique because you can operate on your
heart you or I can't do that no all
right an obstetrician is unique because
they can deliver a breech baby
they can reach up and pull out a second
Twin to call the breach extraction they
can put forceps on
these are the skills that make my
profession these are the three skills
that I just mentioned that aren't even
being taught anymore in most training
programs
everything else an obstetrician can do
can be done by somebody else pap smears
well women exams nurse practitioners
midwives family diet practice doctors
women who have hormonal problems or
birth control they can see an
endocrinologist infertility you see an
endocrinologist if you have an abnormal
pap smear and you think you might have
pre-cancer or you find a lump in your
breast you can see a G1 oncologist or a
general surgeon if you need a cesarean
section a general surgeon can do that
you don't need an obstetrician to do
cesarean sections you could just train
your surgeon to do that and then normal
birthing can be done by women midwives
of course I think that I think that's
that's all the special Urology yeah if
you have a problem with your bladder you
know there's you know what's the gy
neurologist can see you so the
generalist OB GYN
is really obsolete
people don't know it yet wow but when
businessmen who run these big corporate
entities figure out that they could hire
maybe three midwives for the price of
one obstetrician
why would you hire an obstetrician
once they figure it out
and my and the Obstetricians aren't
able to do the things that make my
profession unique I think that that it
will implode again not fast enough for
me but yeah yeah but um well why do you
think they haven't figured it out that
it's actually more affordable even
though yeah it's working for them
they're in their own little Ivory Towers
and they they they will never get on
stage and debate
somebody like me and I'm not I'm not I'm
a very I think I'm a very humble soul
for the most part maybe it doesn't come
across in our interview because I'm
purposely trying to do this but but I
respect the fact that these plays went
through the same trial of fire as I said
earlier that I did
but they need to step out of their box a
little bit and see what's outside and
they and they don't we know what they
think
they don't know what we think I have a
good example one of my closest Midwife
friends Beth in Los Angeles she went to
Kaiser one time to give a lunchtime talk
about what she does as a home birth
midwife
and she brought her
her little suitcase with her little you
know her birth bag and she laid it out
on a table
and the whole the residence there had no
idea
that she carried an IV stuff or that she
had a thing to listen to the baby with
or that she had pitocin and ampicillin
and Lidocaine and that she could sow
they had no idea but we know everything
we know what they can do they just don't
know what midwives can do so it belongs
to the people that are listening that
are going to be having babies in the
future to seek these things out and
spread this information if you want to
go to an OB because you love your OB
that's fine but make sure your OB is
competent
and if not ask questions and seek out
seek out prenatal care also maybe
simultaneously from a midwife so even if
you're going to deliver with your OB in
the hospital you're going to be less
likely to develop preeclampsia less
likely to develop gestational diabetes
because the Midwife is going to spend an
hour at her prenatal visit with you well
your doctor is going to give you 10
minutes if you're lucky
and if you can stay healthy then the
likelihood that you're going to end up
with any sort of intervention or sort of
recommendation for induction those sorts
of things is going to be much much less
I want to share a little example of when
I was pregnant with my third I wasn't
going to get an ultrasound with each one
I ended up getting one ultrasound but
this one I was like I'm not sure if I
want one but then like towards the end
of my pregnancy I decided I do want to
get one and I had Kaiser at the time and
so my Midwife said oh why don't you just
go to the hospital with your Kaiser
insurance and get an ultrasound I think
it was like past 30 weeks pregnant so
it's the first time I showed up at the
hospital at 30 weeks pregnant and the
hospital staff kind of freaked out like
how is this the first time you're coming
we don't have anything on file I'm like
you know yeah I just decided I'm gonna
get an ultrasound I'm having a home
birth and at every single hospital staff
that I encountered the nurse said we
need to let you know that we don't
recommend home birth we don't you're
saying you're gonna have a homework we
don't recommend it it is dangerous we
had like a regurgitated type of thing
that they had to say they handed me a
pamphlet explain the whole thing and I'm
like oh I know it's gonna be my third
home Earth I you know I feel very safe
home birthing but thank you and then I
finally got to the physician the OB GYN
and he was a really awesome physician he
said to me he's like look we have to
tell you that we don't recommend home
birthing what I just wanted I know I
know we have to tell you that but seeing
that this is going to be your third home
birth you're probably gonna be fine I
know that I don't you know I don't see
the 95 of women that have safe healthy
home births that don't need to come in I
only see the five percent that need my
help so I'm not going to call from your
Midwife after you give birth say oh look
all Good's here and I thought that was
really intellectually honest with him
and I really appreciate that about him
and it just makes me think how women
listening might have totally different
experiences someone listening might have
had a very traumatic Hospital birth um
through the Cascade of interventions
that we're talking about today and
someone else might have had a really
wonderful experience where they feel
very safe and all that to just say the
human and there's so much human aspect
to it depending on your physician and
and your provider but I don't know if
provider is a word that you like no it's
a word I hate yeah why not you like that
word I like the word practitioner if
you're going to talk about it because
because we're professionals and then
we're provider is is sort of demeaning
and it was a term that came up that was
devised by insurance companies
to get rid of the term doctor because
they you know the doctor-patient
relationship was sort of sacred and they
wanted to insert themselves in between
it and no it's marketing it's purely
marketing
um so they came up with a book of
providers
that's such a demeaning term I mean is
the person that
you know Cuts your hair as a hair
stylist or their provider yeah I mean
it's just a it's a it's a non yeah it's
a non-descriptive vague term that is
meant to de-personalize
I don't remember where I was going with
that other than that I think it's good
to ask questions be open to you know
just thinking why is this my accepted
standard of we go to the hospital when
we're and it's almost like a fear-based
thing like when I first wanted to have
my when I was pregnant with my first and
I said I want to have a home birth and
my husband's like oh I don't know about
that I don't I don't know like because
you know he didn't know anything about
home birthing but then we watched the
documentary The Business of Being Born
and he's like oh yeah I want that I want
I want a home birth that that makes a
lot of sense I think a lot of times we
just don't know a lot of people just
don't know any difference any any other
reason to think differently and we
always just trust doctors and their
their model must be the best model out
there because that's just what we're
kind of taught to think
yeah I was already convinced about the
the need to change the model before that
movie came out in 2008 uh The Business
of Being Born By uh Abby I've seen a
Ricky Lake but that movie is they're
having their 15-year sort of uh reunion
and that movie everything in that movie
still applies today which is rather sad
wow that there's been very little change
in 15 years which is what I talked about
that is really sad that is really sad
most residents have never seen a normal
birth
an unmedicated what I would call I mean
there's a big difference between how
some people Define natural birth yeah
somebody built a financial birth as a
baby coming out of the vagina and that's
different from an unmedicated
uninterrupted private birth which is
residents never see that and the reason
residents never see that is because the
way the hospital model trains them in
the way they work is that they're not
taking care of people in labor they
don't ever watch a woman in labor
they've never had to sit for 10 hours on
a couch
watching the sounds that she makes the
movements that she makes the the things
that she asked for the the handing her
something to drink or a spoonful of
Honey or they don't have to do any of
that they're called to the room by the
nurse when they're when it's time for it
to catch the baby they put on their
hazmat suit they put their gloves on
they kept they they put the woman up in
stirrups generally is that still
happening oh yeah that still happens in
most hospitals yes and again I remember
to all your viewers that that you're
asking me about these things this is
obviously this isn't always or ever or
never yes that's like so important and
everybody's story is their own story but
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to bring Enlightenment so that people
can understand that if they make this
Choice there are here are the
consequences of this choice and here are
the benefits of this choice and if you
make that choice here's the as opposed
to getting the skewed piece of
information so they're called to catch
the baby they write the orders
they may sew up the laceration or the PC
on whatever and then they they never see
the woman again
that's how that's how residents are
trained now maybe they'll have a few of
their own clients in their own clinic
and they'll see them to like go home at
two days postpartum and then they'll see
them back in six weeks
but that that other 40 days
the woman's on her own that's not the
Midwifery model at all no not at all
midwives make home visits they hook you
up with lactation Consultants midwives
will they're available 24 7 and you know
if you call you're going to get the
person who knows you you're not going to
get the doc on call so I definitely had
that where I would you know especially
after my first when I had so many
questions I called my Midwife even in
the middle of the night and crying like
oh it's so hard I can't figure out how
to breastfeed this is so hard she's like
talking me through it it's just amazing
yeah yeah it's a it's again it's part of
the difference in the model of care and
and and you can't see watch for signs of
postpartum depression you can't watch
for signs of you know postpartum
preeclampsia which happens if you send
them home on day one or two and then
don't see them again for six weeks it's
it again it's part of that's the part of
the medical system now there are people
that are trying to make changes and
maybe getting visiting Home Nurses and
stuff like that yeah that's okay but
you're also having those will also be
strangers
and and how invested in you are they
that's that's the thing so anyway that's
where I was going with the idea that the
system is the problem as we've said
multiple times and I'll keep saying it
again and what would be really nice for
training in the future would for you be
to have home birth midwives come and
spend some time in labor and delivery
now we before covid we when we
transferred a patient in the hospital we
would come and stay with them so we we I
knew the hospital was anyway because I
was there for 28 years before I left so
I knew how the hospital worked but
midwives know how the hospital works
but the reverse isn't true so having
nurses or or residents spend a month
with a home birth midwife
having that would be incredible yeah you
know breaking the silos is as my friend
Augustine Colebrook likes to say is
because everybody's in their own little
Silo and they never cross over and if we
could we could have that sort of
crossover we'd have much more
collaboration and there wouldn't be this
idea that that home birth is a disaster
because I'm only seeing the five percent
it's smaller than that but you know most
home birth transfers are non-emergent
they're essentially women in labor who
just need some relief yep it's really
really rare to have a 9-1-1 home birth
transport from a properly selected
client
in the care of a competent practitioner
and that's just not kind of the image
people have like they just hear like a I
don't know because you only hear about
the planes that crash
you know and not you know there's a
million plants that land safely every
week yeah and there's probably zero
plane crashes or one but that's the one
that will be on the news yeah absolutely
and so that would that again
that's a problem with our society is
that you know you want clicks you nobody
there's no wouldn't it be great if we
had a newspaper
that said nothing happened today yeah
you know headline everybody made it to
work on time today no nobody would read
it though yeah or just a good thing that
a Good Samaritan did this for somebody
like yeah they may have one of those
once in a while every once in a while
but it's not the main thing people are
reading for sure yeah so I want to go
back to something you said about signs
of postpartum depression it makes me
think of
this exact thing you were just saying
that the the model is about the live
baby at the end and not caring
potentially very much about the mother
even or the bond between the mother and
the baby really good example here that
we have in Maui we don't have a NICU
here so if there's an issue the baby
will go on a helicopter to Oahu to the
NICU but they don't bring the mother
right even though she just gave birth
and the best thing for that baby is to
be close to the mother the colostrum
from the mother best thing for the baby
but the mother has to go to the airport
after just giving birth booking a flight
on her own to get to Oahu to eventually
see her baby 24 hours later most likely
most of the time I know three women who
this has happened to and the the trauma
from that alone not not only just for
the the mother but also the baby that
the baby it's the best thing for that
baby's health is to have the colostrum
and the breast milk from the mother to
feel the closeness of the man that been
in her womb for nine months and there is
no I don't know why that is not
something that is cared for in this
model because it could very easily just
put the mother on the helicopter with
the baby things like that that could
make it better for both mom and baby
again it's because they're not thinking
in the in the in the mammalian model or
the Midwifery model of care the baby's
the one that needs attention and again
it it they've lost the connection of a
mother and baby as a unit now I
understand some babies are so severely
injured or ill that they were going to
need to be in isolate on cooling blanket
or whatever else yeah but you could
still have the mother
touching their baby talking to their
baby
baby we don't know what the baby's
conscious or not consciously hearing and
we and certainly
um the touch you know we know that when
a baby's put on a mother's chest it
regulates four things really well it
regulates baby's breathing their
temperature their blood sugar a missing
one but that's okay when a baby needs
resuscitation
all right the last thing that you could
do unless unless it's one of those very
severe rare cases is cut the cord but
what's the first thing that they do all
right if the baby's got a pulsation in
the cord if the baby's heart rate is
beating and there's a pulsation in the
cord that means the baby's still
exchanging with the mother
so if a baby seems to be floppy and
needs oxygen or needs resuscitation why
are you clamping the cord if that's its
source of oxygen foreign
but we have to take the baby to the
warmer well why do you have to take the
baby to the world well that's the way we
do it it's like well that's not a reason
to do something is because you've been
doing it the wrong way for so long makes
you think it's right it's time to
reevaluate how you think
if you need to resuscitate the baby do
it here
I mean observe the baby here yeah and
this isn't speed here oh yeah but what's
visual so people can see what I'm doing
right on your chest the mother chest um
of course like you said also it doesn't
speak to the the rare outlier cases with
the extremes nothing that we're talking
about today is always yeah or never it's
just I want people to get an
understanding of how wrong we've been
and some of sort of the back background
of why we've been so wrong yeah and how
the challenges are to to get things to
change yeah it's not going to change
when the people running the show don't
want it to change
and the change is going to have to come
from demand again from women yeah
absolutely so can you walk us through
the standard procedures that happened at
the hospital and explain maybe a
breakdown of pros and cons to those
things
okay such as excuse me like if you start
from the beginning like we want to
induce you at 39 weeks because we think
your baby is going to be too big or for
another type of Reason okay
again we can't we there are times where
this is true but that they're so rare
that it's it's worthy of of disdain so
let's talk about them
the idea that a doctor knows how big
your baby's going to be and that nature
would design a baby inside of you that's
too big to fit out and that the idea
that your pelvis is a fixed organ and
the baby is a is a cement doll
um is wrong baby's head's mold pelvises
expand changing positions by the way the
worst position that you can be in as far
as opening to your pelvis is laying flat
on your back what are women mostly
laying in when they're in labor is it on
their back
so when you can open up your pelvis up
as much as 30 by being upright or on all
fours pushing in stirrups is probably
not the best way to push so they do all
these things but inducing your labor for
these sorts of indications like your
fluid's too low your baby's too big your
hips are too small uh your placenta is
looking old
this is this is you know can I I guess I
can say this is [__] it really is
[__] but it's but the doctors are
taught that and I really do
you have to wonder two things like
whenever you have these situations do
the doctors believe what they're saying
or they know it's [__] and they say
it because that's what they're told to
say that's a good question yeah it might
be it might depend on the person yeah I
think it's some of both but either way
it's it's it's true like a broken clock
is true sometimes they're right but most
of the time they're not right and every
woman my very her very nature deserves
to have Labor on her own terms and the
problem with what they when they cry
wolf all the time like that is that when
there is an actual indication to induce
somebody you're gonna have women who
aren't going to believe it so what would
be like the downsides then to getting
induced so someone's like well okay well
I'll take my chances what if my baby's
too big well let's let's go back and
talk about why nature does things the
way nature does things when you have a
surge or a contraction whatever you want
to call it you put out
neurotransmitters
and the four main ones that I would
think that you put out are you put out
oxytocin which is your
contraction hormone but it's also your
bonding and your love hormone and your
milk let down hormone it's amazing
amazing the drug or uh hormone uh you
put out adrenaline we've already talked
about adrenaline in a way when a mammal
puts out adrenaline what does it do to
the contractions spaces them out a
little bit so it gives the mother a
little bit more of a break before the
next one comes you put on cortisol
what's cortisol do it's your stress
hormone when you're under stress when
you're fearful or whatever else you're
secreting cortisol
and then you put out endorphins and
endorphins are your body's own opiates
so and that helps you deal with this
this discomfort right so you're putting
all those things out and the
neurotransmitters receive them they then
you have about three four minutes where
they can regenerate The receptors
regenerate the neurotransmitters
regenerate and the whole thing starts
over and it gets you through Labor and
when you can move and when you can do
these things people always say like how
can you do it at home without an
epidermal well it's because I can get in
water I can get in the shower I can move
I can get somebody to rub my hips I can
get my bozoed I can have all these
things done to me at home where if
you're laboring in the hospital on a bed
with the belts on you can't not to
mention the fear makes it more painful
so what happens when you're fearful and
you're in more pain and you're stuck in
a hospital you ask for a epidural
epidural
doctors who don't think like this to
think that they'll think they'll equate
it to a toothache why would you ever
want to have your tooth drilled without
lidocaine you wouldn't but a tooth is an
inanimate object and a woman in labor is
not an inanimate object and so 80 of
women at most hospitals will get an
epidural so you get an epidural and
suddenly you're not in pain anymore
so what happens to those
neurotransmitters
well adrenaline's gone the cortisol is
gone the endorphins are gone and your
oxytocin spaces out a little bit okay
that may be fine for you at some point
they say your contractions are spaced
out maybe we need to add some pitocin so
now you're adding an artificial drug
which is where the point where I'm going
to get to about induction in a second
but I'm going to I'm going the circuit
it's all very important
yeah it's to me because if you start to
think like this once you start thinking
like this you can't unthink like this
yeah
but when you're in labor and you're
having contraction every three minutes
or so
you have a partner
that's in labor with you just to get
emotional about this your baby your
baby's world has been the same pretty
much for nine months
suddenly your baby's world is changing
and it's getting squeezed
and oops there goes all the water and
now it's really getting squeezed
and every three minutes it's getting a
waft of Mom's oxytocin adrenaline
cortisol and endorphins and so you're
helping yourself deal with the
discomfort but you're also communicating
directly with your baby it's part of
that Symphony that I was talking about
it's just a beautiful Symphony and so
your baby gets a waft of your oxytocin
and goes while I'm there I'm good
your adrenaline helps the baby cope with
the discomfort your endorphins help the
baby and the cortisol helps the baby and
because the baby has no experience of
this it never doesn't know what's going
on so you're giving it now you give a
woman an epidural
and boom
mom's cut off from baby
baby's still getting squeezed every
three minutes or four minutes or maybe
that spaces out and they say Ad pitocin
so now the contractions are pretty
intense and they're every two to three
minutes
and there's no communication with Mom so
what happens to the baby in that
situation you begin to see the baby's
heart rate rise
or you begin to see D cells and somebody
comes in the room and says oh we need to
adjust your monitor we need to turn you
on your side baby's not tolerating labor
very well
and then eventually it becomes if it's
not if you're not far enough along they
say you know they diagnose you as fetal
intolerance to labor or arrest and then
you get a C-section and they say thank
God you were in the hospital and had a
C-section because what would have
happened if this had happened to you at
home not having any concept of what they
just said was one of the dumbest things
they could ever say because when you
don't mess with it this is a very rare
thing that happens at home but it
happens in the hospital all the time
it's the number one diagnosis for
cesarean section is fetal intolerance to
labor wow I mean it reminds me of a
quote that you said I saw it on your
website it says when you end up meddling
with birth you end up needing technology
yeah and so all the while there's
claiming thank goodness for technology
because you're you know you wouldn't
have survived this without this but not
realizing that it was the meddling with
first that caused the need for the
technology yeah the bad analogy is that
the firemen come to your house and start
a fire and then you call them to put the
fire out they say
aren't we great for putting out your
fire it's like no no no you well you
started the fire yeah so so that that
that's a that's a really important thing
that that
my colleagues don't don't know they
don't understand or they ignore it
because if you if you had a conversation
with somebody where you had the time to
sit with somebody who doesn't think like
I do
and you ask them so
counter that argument I don't know what
they would say
all right I just don't I don't know what
they would say because really never had
that conversation because people get
very uncomfortable
when you
shake up their world they don't they
don't like it and I'm not trying to make
them uncomfortable but I would love to
have a conversation which gets which is
why I'm yeah on your on your uh podcast
so getting back to the whole idea of
induction which is what led me to this
place in the first place yeah is that
pitocin
is not oxytocin
let's be very clear about that
sometimes the viewers are used
interchangeably by your doctor or by the
pharmaceutical companies or even by the
American College of OB GYN
they'll they'll use the word oxytocin
it's not the same oxytocin does all
kinds of things pitocin does one thing
mainly it causes your uterus to contract
right it doesn't cause milk letdown it
doesn't make you feel loved
okay yeah so those are the things that
it doesn't do so when you put someone on
Pitocin for an induction
they're not going to be secreting
oxytocin and your baby's going to go
through its entire labor without being
exposed to your oxytocin that's no
sometimes they start pitocin you get
cracking and rolling and they turn the
pitocin off okay great yeah I mean I'm
still still not great because you're
still giving somebody an artificial
medication
and again every time you interfere with
nature you end up eating technology so
you're doing something that will have a
ripple effect we don't know what that
Ripple affect me maybe it will be
something in the baby's epigenetics
maybe it'll be something in the baby's
neural Pathways that for that are
forming in labor and we won't know that
you have to look at how we give birth
really matters it's pretty clear to me
that we're doing a lot of things wrong
anytime you have a transaction that
occurs between me and you
you're going to have better service
better outcomes than when you put a
middleman in between
every time you put a middleman in
between the middleman probably makes the
most money
and and and is not responsible for
something
it's again it's a flaw in the Health
Care system when doctors became
employees of hospitals
that's a real problem Ellen because
my fiduciary duty is to the patient I'm
taking care of
a doctor who works for Kaiser or I'm not
picking on Kaiser but HMO it's just the
one that we know
um their fiduciary duty as to who is to
Kaiser oh yeah yeah because if they do
something that Kaiser doesn't like
they can get fired
so they have a conflict of interest
and once you start developing these
sorts of conflicts of interest of
fiduciary duties which is the duty to do
right by the person that's what it means
sort of
um
you you how do you trust is broken
yeah you know you were let's say in last
pregnancy you use Zofran for your
morning sickness I'm not saying that you
know first we try all kinds of herbal
stuff and natural stuff but say you use
Zofran for your for your sickness now
you're pregnant with a second time and
you've changed insurance companies and I
want to write your prescription for
Zofran but your insurance company it's
not on their formulary you can't have it
what do you mean I can't have it nope
you can't have it now a lot of people
will come to me and say they can't have
it and I'll say no no no
you can have it your insurance company
is not going to pay for it so you can
pay for it out of pocket
but people don't understand that if
people will say to me I've heard it all
the time my insurance company says I
need to do this
like I want your listeners to understand
your insurance company has no power over
you
they may have some Financial things but
they can't tell you what to do or what
not to do and you have the right to say
no
knowing our world is a complete sentence
if somebody says I want to do this to
you now I want to do a vaginal examiner
and you say no
they that's it yeah they can't yeah
and if they and again the use of
coercion which is used every day in
doctor's offices even whether it's
subtle or overt
um the threats of Child Protective
Services the threats of your insurance
not paying
um or just skewing your counseling to
say that you know breach birth is
dangerous your baby's head will get
stuck your baby will die that's what of
course is is
currently unethical and every or every
governing body whether it's the American
Medical Association or ACOG not
organizations I'm big fans of by the way
um because I think they're they're
corrupted as well but I but
um everybody's statement about the use
of coerison is that it's unacceptable
and then every single day in every
single doctor's office and every single
hospital it's used and you know you
can't you can't eliminate your bias
entirely from um from how you how you
talk
to people but at least when I I have
learned it's a technique that I wasn't
learned in residency but I've learned to
be very clear with people that these are
my opinions and that there are you know
I want you to seek out other options I
don't want to tell you what to do
I want you to take this information do
the do your due diligence and then come
back and let me no like a really ethical
thing to do with breach birth
for a doctor that doesn't do breach
birth it's just say the woman I don't do
breach birth but Dr Chavira over there
or Dr Brock over there or Dr fishbein
that crazy guy that does them at home
they know how to do breach birth right
go have a conversation with them or a
consult with them and then call me and
let me know what you said and we'll talk
about it that would be completely
ethical but it's not ethical for him to
tell you that your only option is a
C-section and that and that he'll do it
absolutely right
I want to get back to the Cascade of
interventions when I mentioned getting
induced you had to go to the pitocin
like you started with the pitocin but
then also the epidural and potentially
the C-section so like because it's all
connected so I feel like you touched on
that pretty well let's let's talk about
a few other things that are really
common procedures to do in hospitals
like continuous fetal monitoring
monitoring why do they do it what are
the benefits and the cons
okay continuous female monitoring came
in Vogue in the 70s it was done on a
very small sample and they thought that
this is going to be brilliant because
we're going to end neonatal intrapartum
death
and cerebral palsy
and when they brought it into play
C-section rates the United States were
five percent after 50 years of using
continuous fatal monitoring and many
many studies including some really
Landmark studies showing that
has done nothing
to decrease the rate of cerebral palsy
it may have slightly decreased
intrapartum death
but nothing to do the the its primary
objective was to decrease the risk of
brain damage to babies in labor
it's done none of that but the C-section
really has gone up 500 percent
so all the continual seal monitoring has
done and I think that most doctors are
in agreement with this
is that it's useless in preventing the
things that it was designed to prevent
for
the why is it still used
because we talked about it earlier once
the policy is put into place
like the Pediatric policy of doing
newborn exams on everybody
it's very hard to get rid of it because
Risk Managers like it because it's
probably a labor saver for nurses
somebody can sit out at the desk
and like air traffic controllers they
can watch nine people in labor at the
same time
they don't care that it's limiting the
woman's movement
that reading those tracings and the
what's called category two is this vague
nebulous thing that goes all the way
from like a little bit abnormal to very
abnormal and may not have any
correlation with outcomes it's a big
paper that came out by a guy named Steve
Clark last year that I mean that was an
opinion piece I think but it was really
sort of brilliantly written I thought
that
you you can't really interpret them and
so they're often misinterpreted
it's why the C-section rate goes up
because you'll see
how many C-sections are done for an
abnormal fetal heart rate tracing where
they tell you your baby doesn't look
like it's doing well and we need to do a
C-section and they call it an emergency
all right but they take 40 minutes to
get you on the table
okay wow yeah all right that's really
telling I mean a lot of women will call
me I said I had an emergency C-section
and I'll just suddenly ask them later on
and says like once they decided to do a
C-section how long did it take for them
to get you on the table I said yeah it
was within an hour and I go that's not
an emergency that's not how we Define an
emergency but then and then they'll get
a baby that comes out screaming with
apgars of Nine and Nine and normal blood
gas
so they were wrong but they'll say thank
God we did the C-section because look we
got a great baby if we would have waited
longer we would that may be true but
it's probably most often not true and
you said that the baby was in trouble
now and if a baby's in trouble now how
come it came out so good and if you were
really if it really was an emergency you
wouldn't wait 40 minutes to get her on
the table you you'd call a crash we call
it a crash hit the button on the wall
and everybody runs in and gets you back
there and you can sometimes get a baby
out in 10 to 15 minutes probably from
the time you call a crash at a good at a
good hospital with in-house
anesthesiologists and or crew and other
hospitals it's going to take longer it's
going to take 30 minutes or more vaginal
birth after cesarean is something that
people think well you should do in the
hospital because what if something goes
wrong and the uterus ruptures well the
uterus ruptures depending on how the
baby's heart rate was before that and it
truly ruptures as opposed to scar
separating you have about eight eight to
ten fifteen minutes at the most to get a
baby out before It suffers irreversible
injury
um most hospitals can't get a baby out
that fast anyway
so the idea that just because you're in
a hospital you're gonna have a better
outcome than at home when that really
rare rare thing happens where you have a
true uterine rupture it's probably
fallacious as well it's probably not
true that in in many instances you're
still going to get a very bad outcome
when that happens and it's not
predictable and it's not something that
people should have a repeat C-section
for because because it of this rare
occurrence it should be something that
people are given true informed consent
on and then allow them to make that
decision hospitals that ban vbac which
is really common like there are some on
Hawaii that ban vbac I know that
um that's completely unethical why do
you think it's unethical well first of
all because ACOG says it's unethical
which is one of the things I agree with
them on but secondly because the the
risk is is a lot smaller than the risk
of an emergency C-section for every
other thing that happens in pregnancy
in other words they'll say they can't do
it because they don't have in-house
anesthesia and what happens if it if the
if that happened
but almost all emergency C-sections are
done for reasons other than vbac
placental abruption cord prolapse these
sorts of things and they handle those
just fine
so yeah so why are they doing it because
an Ethics ethics is something called
there's it's totally called beneficence
bath Essex which is doing what's best
for the patient and ultimately what's
best for the patient should be
determined by who
the patient the patient right yeah right
and all this all these topics were
hitting that are common practice in
hospitals can make it more likely to end
up with a C-section and then what are
the risks of the C-section most people
don't even think that there are actually
even risks with a C-section can you get
to that yeah well sure we talk a little
bit about yeah we did Downstream
consequences they don't consider the
C-section to be something that that
again is putting the mother at greater
risk it's major abdominal surgery they
don't describe it that way though yeah
they describe it as something oh we do
it all the time it takes 30 minutes you
know you'll be in the recovery room with
your baby right after and a lot of
hospitals are doing much better about
gentle I don't like that term gentle
cesarean but that's the term where they
put the baby skin to skin and sometimes
they even let the mom reach down yeah
and pull the baby out you've seen videos
on you yeah I love that they're doing
more of that where they're keeping the
baby in the operating room with the mom
baby going to the nursery with Mom A lot
of times it's a staffing issue that they
won't let that happen which is another
BS explanation yeah yeah well then then
you have a scarred uterus you have the
risk of poor wound healing and Scar
opening up and that takes weeks to heal
you have the risk to Future pregnancies
you have an increased risk of injury to
your bladder bowel adhesions bowel
obstruction chronic pain longer recovery
longer recovery uh sometimes evidence
does seem to support more dysfunctional
breastfeeding when that happens so and
then there's also the factor of sorry to
interrupt but the the factor of the
benefits of a vaginal delivery for the
baby's immune system yeah I was going to
say that microbiome and the epigenetics
of the baby long term of of being born
in a way that nature didn't design
I don't think any doctor talks like I do
who doesn't say that C-sections for some
are a godsend yeah absolutely right and
we're not we're not bashing them and but
but the percentage should be ten percent
um maybe I mean you know in this day and
age but it certainly shouldn't be 30 35
there you know some hospitals have 40 50
cesarean section rate no doctor is going
to openly say yeah I have a 60 C-section
right really you know they're gonna lie
who's going to say that if you ask your
doctor what a C-section rate is a lot of
by the way a lot of them won't know
because they don't they don't keep track
yeah because it's not and they don't log
they don't log them in I I didn't for my
first 28 years in practice I didn't keep
track of my purse I read somewhere that
their higher rates of C-sections at
certain times of the day when the doctor
wants to get home in time for dinner or
go in time well that seems to be
relatively true there is a there was a
paper that came out that showed Peaks at
like 7 A.M and 5 p.m yeah because nature
we know designs women to have C-sections
at 7am and 5 PM 7am is to get people so
the doctor can get to the office and 5
PM is the doctor can get home get home
in time for dinner yeah and again
because the way the system is set up
it's hard for me to blame doctors who
are under the pressures of getting women
delivered to not fall into the Trap of
being impatient right the interesting
thing about the impatient thing was they
thought okay if doctors want to get home
for supper let's get rid of that
pressure and let's get something called
laborous
laborers are like doctors who spend a
12-hour shift in the hospital and they
deliver all the babies during that
12-hour shift and they thought well
since there's no pressure for them to
deliver the babies we'll have lower
C-section rates
didn't work that way what happened was
you had C-section rates that were
commiserable with the way the doctor
practiced
so some of the labor has set C-section
rates of 10 and some of these laborers
had C-section rates of 50 wow so it
wasn't based on again it wasn't based on
the system it was it was what's called
stage one thinking rather than figure
out whether fetal monitoring is going to
work or labor curves are going to work
or or laborers are going to work they
just put it in play
and they see what happens because that
sounds good without them ever asking
themselves the real question is it
actually going to do good mm-hmm
and the getting back
into labor all the all that stuff that's
factored in that they're not considering
yeah women should really reconsider even
if they want a hospital birth consider
hiring a doula for sure and consider
even hiring a midwife as what's called a
monitories
which is one that they can come to your
house because a doula can't do medical
stuff they can't do a vaginal exam they
can't listen to your baby uh legally
anyway they probably do sometimes but um
but uh but that way you can you can if
you want to deliver at the hospital
because you feel it safer for you then
the Midwife will keep you at home until
you're nine centimeters and then there's
far less time
for the hospital to get impatient with
you and to restrict you and to do all
those things that are anti-mammalian
to you that disrupt your labor and you
end up with pitocin and an epidural and
all the Cascade of interventions again
these are General instructions and a lot
of doctors will say well if your Auto
brakes come right in
absolutely not you should be talking to
somebody and they should ask you
questions like is the fluid clear is
your baby moving are you having any
contractions is there any blood if no if
ever though if you answer all those
questions in the right way there's
absolutely no reason to go to the
hospitals matter of fact it's
detrimental to go to the hospital
because now you're sitting in a place
with different bacteria
where people are going to want to move
you along because they don't have an
endless enough a number of empty rooms
or nursing staff to take care of you and
you're more likely to go into natural
labor when you're feeling safe and
secure and in a place where you're not
being meddled with as opposed to going
someplace with bright sterile lights and
all these people entering the room that
you've never seen before putting on a
gown that like going back to this whole
thing that we're talking about yeah I
love it I love that way you said that
because that's exactly right
right people that ma'am again if people
just think yeah we're human and we think
and we've got higher reasoning and stuff
like that sometimes it's a detriment
when it comes to primitive brain
functions like breathing or digestion
like I said before but we are mammalian
our instincts are there it works right
most of the time
and when it doesn't then medicine is
important but if you go into the medical
model right away from the moment you go
in for your first prenatal visit you'll
you'll be
not going to use that term you'll see
some seeds of Doubt will be planted I
was going to say the word grooming but
I'm not going to say that because it's
yeah that's a controversial work but you
will be so I said it anyway because
that's just to me I can't help myself
um but you'll be there'll be seeds of
doubt you'll be oh you know your husband
is six foot five and you're only five
foot two uh that baby you're gonna yeah
baby's gonna have to come out early or
oh you're over 35 you know your placenta
is for sure gonna die early you know and
they'll and they'll say things like that
or they'll do an ultrasound at 20 weeks
and they'll see
one little abnormal marker
and a woman that's already had normal
genetic screening that nipt testing
that's done around 10 11 weeks
and it means absolutely nothing and you
know it and I know it but the Maternal
Fetal Medicine doctor will say well this
little thing in the in the brain doesn't
really mean anything but I want to see
you back in six weeks just to be sure
it's gone so what is that woman thinking
about for six weeks
um there's something wrong with my
baby's brain
it's kind of like out of the movie uh
Inception where the guy says don't think
about elephants yeah absolutely and then
you're thinking about it yeah you can't
not think about it so they they plant
these seeds of Doubt all along
and then you're like I said earlier
you're bathing your baby in anxiety
hormones and then you're Googling stuff
and then you know your family members
who are maybe anti-natural birth or
anti-home birth are are lathering you
with their stories of how their doctor
saved them
you know that they got induced and the
baby got in trouble and thank God I was
in the hospital what would you do if
that happened at home that that whole
thing over and over again
no I I hear it like a broken record so
sometimes I think I probably am
repetitive in what I say but I I it's so
passionate for me
understandably so because you've been on
both sides of the coin you've seen one
model of care and the other model care
so I was the other model of care yeah I
was the guy in the Hazmat suit that
clamped your cord and took the baby over
to the warmer that was me had I not had
the Good Fortune for the wrong reason of
meeting midwives
I'd still be that guy
and do you think was it very much just
this is what I was taught and this is
just the way it is yeah I mean I was
taught at one of the best hospitals in
the country so how could they be wrong
how could they not know something
but I was lucky though you asked another
question about breaching part of the
reason that I was lucky is because in
the early 80s it was still
something that was being taught and part
of Cedar Sinai uh rotation I got to
spend four months at L.A County USC
Hospital which was the county hospital
in downtown L.A which was the busiest
Hospital in the country at that time
they were doing about twenty two
thousand bursts a year there which is
about 65 babies a day whoa in that
hospital and as the resident on the
floor 65 babies a day breaches are three
percent of the population you're going
to see at least two breaches every day
twins are about three percent of the
population you're going to see at least
two sets of twins every day for every
other night for four months so I got the
training which no one's going to get
anymore and that's a problem and that's
a real problem I'm not expecting people
who don't know how to do stuff to do
stuff
but I am expecting them to be honest and
explain that to their patients that they
don't know how to do stuff it's not that
the stuff that they don't know how to do
is wrong it's just that they don't know
how to do it and they need to then we
need to start retraining these people we
need to take that back to them and and
retraining the Next Generation you can't
expect a doctor's been out in 20 years
in practice
to suddenly start doing something that
he's never been comfortable with before
but
medical students and residents they're
sponges
they want to learn this stuff yeah and I
believe they're generally getting into
it for because they want to help people
absolutely you have to at this day and
age there's very little other reason the
monetary reasons have sort of been taken
away
so you have to do it because you you
want to help people
but to not be able to learn the skills
that we talked about earlier to
to not be taught those in the place
where you're supposed to be taught
and then to come out and build yourself
as an expert
to know that I'm an expert in OB and yet
I don't do these two main things that if
you add breaches and twins together
that's six percent of all women that's
one out of every 16 women that's
pregnant that you don't know how to take
care of that makes you an expert can you
imagine what a cardiologist one out of
every 16 people with heart problems
cardiologists didn't know how to take
care of that yeah that's not something
that would ever be acceptable to a
Cardiologist or a Cardiology residency
yeah but it's the norm
can you explain the difference between
the terms high risk and low-risk
pregnancies and your thoughts on that
yeah high risk is in the eyes of the
beholder
and it's it's it's a it's a bad term
it's worse than provider
it's a it's a bad term and the reason
it's a bad term is because it it again
it paints a picture of something that's
risky
and life itself has risks we don't
consider
driving down the hill to the market on
the coast to be high risk but there is
risk involved with it to some people
that might be high risk they may be
agoraphobic people who don't want to
leave their house because they're
they're nervous so risk is relative to
what what your what your history what
your values are so I'll give you an
example
um a woman with a placenta previa is
high risk okay right that woman cannot
deliver vaginally and if she tries she
will
bleed out okay bubbles for sure and your
baby will die okay all right a woman
with hypertension
isn't necessarily high risk
she may become high risk but she will be
labeled high risk from the date they
walk in and they start with the problem
list thing again and they label that
they have a problem a woman with
hypothyroidism who's on Synthroid
that will be labeled high risk and some
midlife in certain states are not
allowed to take care why
if the birth has nothing to do with that
if her thyroid is working fine on
medication or her hypertension is well
controlled what's going to happen in
labor if she does I'm not talking about
preeclamptics but what's going to happen
in labor if her blood pressure gets
really really high in labor at home then
we've heard of this thing called a car
we put them in the car and we drive him
to the hospital and they can be then
taken care of there same thing with the
diabetic diabetics always been labeled
high risk but diabetics in 2023 are not
the same as diabetics in 1980. we have
implants
and we have cell phones and a woman
who's a diabetic now can look at real
time and what her blood sugar is and if
it's a little bit High she could push a
button if it's a little bit low she
could need something eat some food so
she can keep herself well controlled but
yet diabetic will be labeled high risk
all of them a woman with a breech baby
will be labeled high risk a woman who's
over 35 one of the dumbest things ever
will be labeled high risk by people who
want to label somebody high risk and
here's a good question by telling a
woman she's high risk
do you make her more high risk and the
answer is yes I mean yeah I think that's
something definitely missing in the our
medical schooling the importance of the
power of the mind that is this is not
really taken into consideration but
you've heard of white coats syndrome
there are women that come into the
office and their blood pressures are 140
over 80. they go home and it's 120 over
70. consistently 120 over 70. yeah but
if they're 140 over 80 and they go to a
physician or a HMO that has a algorithm
they'll say well that's hypertensive we
need to talk about starting fetal
testing on you and inducing your labor
at 39 weeks or even earlier if there's a
problem maybe even giving you steroids I
mean again they're they they can't
individualize their care
so part of that is their their own human
nature and part of that is their
training your children when they grow up
all right we'll never look at Birth with
the same sort of anxiety that people on
the west side of Los Angeles as children
generally will look at yeah well see
birth as normal normal natural function
of the body and they'll look at it
differently so we talked a lot about
what is wrong with our modern medical
system for birth can you touch on what
you see as that they're doing right or
what we can improve on it's a little
positive note going what would you like
to see change what do you think is like
an optimal you know model of care for
women and birth well Midwifery for
obstetrics we're talking about not not
all all Health Care yes I mean the
medical model is it's probably seen its
time and needs to needs to go yeah yeah
we're talking birth I'm not talking
about heart surgery or cancer surgery or
you know those sorts of things I'm
talking about the model of of taking
your kid to the pediatrician every year
or getting a pap smear every year
there's no reason for those sorts of
things they've just ingrained in US yeah
all right you if someone's at high risk
for an abnormal pap smear they should
have more than pap smears more than
every year and if someone is in a
monogamous relationship or has never
been sexually active
then she doesn't need a pap smear yeah
okay but we do things in a regular way
so getting away from that but I think
for obstetrics for people listening
Midway hiring a midwife for your
prenatal care is really ultimately
important because you will you will see
another way of doing something and it's
and it's not and midwives are not there
to brainwash you no Midwife is there to
steal you from your doctor because
they're going to get rich doing it
because we don't get rich doing home
birthing
and doctors don't get rich even you know
a salary employees now most doctors so
it's not about the money for most of us
Midwife I think Midwifery model is the
way to go and I think that it has to
come again from anyways I see it
changing but as I said earlier I'm I'm
not old I'm too old to see it change
fast enough for my liking I don't see a
sudden realization that the C-section
rate of 30-some percent United States is
wrong and I don't see the people in
power or running The Residency program
suddenly saying you know what we've been
wrong all along we're going to change
everything that we do that that's
unrealistic I have hope that people are
waking up I'm not really optimistic that
this current system can be fixed and I
think an alternative system will will
rise and the people who seek it out will
be better off for it
and and the more people seek it out you
know if they if you build it they will
come to quote
I think this is a really good question
after this what we just talked about
what about someone who's listening and
they're like look I hear you I would
love to do a homework I just can't
afford it I can't afford a midwife what
do you think is the best tips to help
navigate someone who is choosing a
hospital birth for either financial
reasons or whatever reason
um to have their most optimal experience
good question it's a really good
question yeah ideally the problem is of
course that people have helped most
people have health insurance or Medicaid
but most midwives don't take it because
it doesn't pay well enough
uh it'd be nice if those companies would
would pay for home birth because home
birth would save the insurance company a
lot of money I'm not sure why the
actuaries and people that make those
decisions for insurance companies aren't
jumping at the opportunity to pay for
home birth
because it's like a third of the cost of
a hospital vaginal delivery and probably
a fifth of the cost of a Caesarean but
for those people that can't afford it
sometimes you may have to seek out
a physician who's not in your area you
may have to you may hear of a hospital
that's 50 miles away or across state
lines that has a C-section rate that's
really good if you go online and you get
into the Facebook groups or the
Instagram groups you're gonna there's
gonna be enough talk there's enough
great podcasts out there yeah that talk
about you know these these isolated
people that are doing really good work
and if you have to travel
make it make it something that's it's
that important because it is a life
event it's not a medical procedure it's
not like getting your broken arm set is
that possible though like if you're in
labor to have oh no not if you're like
this you have to plan ahead right right
right yeah you have to plan this way
ahead of time yeah yeah no no yeah if
you're in labor and just suddenly
realize it no I mean like planning ahead
of time to go to a hospital that far
away is that
does that well generally yes you can I
mean if it if it's 50 miles that's no
problem unless it's your fourth baby in
which case you know it's going to come
really fast and then you probably
shouldn't stay home anyway yeah
um there is no great answer right now I
wish I had one for you because I feel
like there are certain things that are
really helpful yeah so like in my in my
birth course I actually worked with a
wonderful Doula on island who gives tips
for those who choose a hospital birth
and what can help them to have their
best experience and basically the topic
of whoever is your birthing partner
whether that's a doula like you
recommend which she also recommends if
you're having a house over at the
crossover it's just hire a doula but if
we're talking financial reasons you
probably can't afford to hire Doula so
who your your birthing partner is uh
likely your your spouse or love partner
to be the best advocate for you and to
help you use your voice and speak
clearly about your birth plan and to
find a physician like there's red flags
right on to know a physician that's
going to work with you for your desires
versus one that isn't you I feel like
you also have spoken on this somewhere
about red flags on what would be about
yeah we did the whole thing about red
flags yeah you feel when you go into
your prenatal visit do you feel worse
when you come out or better if you feel
worse when you come out then that's not
the practitioner for you yeah oh I agree
100 I was going off in a different
tangent with the question but yeah
having your Doula and your partner the
problem of course is if you still have a
hospital that is obtuse yeah then then
you know you don't want to be in for
that fight ahead of time so
theoretically if you can go to your
hospital you know weeks before Labor and
have a conversation with the chart nurse
or conversation with your doctor or
whatever and and say this is what we
want to do are you will you be
supportive of this in labor because you
don't really want that conflict going on
in labor certainly not in the labor room
and if your partner or your sister or
your doula
wants to have a conversation with the
nurse about what they're recommending or
the doctor take it out of the hall
definitely do that leave the birth space
as sacred as you can possibly yes keep
it as quiet and as peaceful you take all
that don't have a TV on yeah people dim
the lights if you can type of things
like there was different things that um
Haley Callahan who's in over of course
it was explaining like bringing
different things uh to help you feel the
most at home and say bringing the pillow
that really makes you feel comfortable
wearing your jammies yeah yes but that's
not going to solve the problem the
bigger problem which is what I was
trying to address I know totally I think
it's all relative if we if we make more
midwives then relevant I mean relative
it's all relevant yeah if we make more
midwives then then then of course if we
have more Supply
and demand will it'll work both ways but
it will also keep the costs down if
there's zero competition then then the
prices won't go up but I would also say
to people who can't say you know say
they can't afford it
rethink that philosophy all right you're
planning to have a child maybe it's oops
and you got pregnant but you got nine
months to figure that out maybe you
could start saving a way
for your children a typical Midwife in
one of the states in the United States
is going to be anywhere from 3 500 to 7
000 depending on you know if you're in
the big cities it's going to be more but
you really can't afford four thousand
dollars
do you really think that two three years
later that four thousand dollars will
have been meaningful that you'll spend
it on something meaningful more
meaningful than the birth of your of
your child
um
I think it really comes down to
priorities too like some for some people
four thousand dollars is a lot of money
but you can find different ways to save
up that money or um ways to make extra
money work some extra shifts like either
your partners or you can barter with
your Midwife theoretically you can also
um instead of having a baby shower where
people give you things that are going to
sit in the in the wrapper until the baby
is five years old have a baby shower
where people just donate to a to a
Gibson go or something yeah ask people
to help support you in that way and um
you I would recommend listening to my my
episodes on Financial Freedom to
learning how to you know cut your cut
certain spending and increase savings
and there's there's a way depending on
your priority most of the time there's
going to be outliers of course but a lot
of the times there are ways to make it
work and two yeah it is a life event and
it's you know other than maybe your
wedding day and even sometimes birth of
your children is even
even more precious than that it's
probably one of the two most precious
days in your life and and to you would
never scrimp on your wedding day and and
so just because you have a you know an
insurance card doesn't mean you have to
use your insurance card it's like the
thing about the prescription it's like
your insurance says you can't have that
well were they to tell you that yeah it
does cost money but it's it's an
investment in in your baby start and and
again because it's so important how your
baby starts out and the idea that for
you and all your future babies if you
can have that first vaginal delivery
the way it's supposed to be unmedicated
um
unfettered immediate skin to skin no
cord clamping until the placenta has
been in a bowl for an hour or two you're
giving your baby the best possible start
that nature design
and all your future babies as well so it
you have to decide what's a priority for
people some people that's not a priority
for them and I understand that when and
those people won't be touched they
probably won't be watching yeah yeah
this episode yeah but I imagine a lot of
people watching or listening to this
episode are maybe in a place of wanting
a v back or maybe they are having twins
so to kind of round out this
conversation what final words of
encouragement do you have for people who
are really looking to go for their V
back and maybe they're getting a lot of
pushback or
um just feeling nervous about it maybe
you can share just your thoughts because
this is kind of your specialty it's like
assisting midwives at home for V backs
and twin and free delivery well vbax not
as much feedback yeah it's really
interesting because be back breach and
Twitter always loved together right
reach and twin requires specific skill
set feedback is just a vaginal birth
yeah that's super important right so so
we'll talk about that one first so let's
just I'll take a little dive into the
numbers so people can understand what
when it's called what's so risky about
it the risk of the scar is separating
which is often called rupture which is a
terrible term because it conjures up the
image of a tire exploding on the freeway
but that's not normally what happens so
only about one out of every 200
vbac labors will have the scar separate
and of those scars that separate only
somewhere between six and sixteen
percent
of those babies will have a terrible
outcome so let's just take 16 because
it's the higher so that's like one in
six
so one in six out of one in 200 which is
actually one and six times one in 200
which is one in twelve hundred so the
actual risk of having a terrible outcome
from a vbac trial of Labor is one in
twelve hundred
wow now that's less than that's a 99.9
plus percent chance that it's not going
to happen
and for that hospitals are Banning vbac
or doctors are refusing to do vbac
because it's too dangerous yet they'll
do all kinds of things that are far
riskier than one in a thousand one in
twelve hundred like what specifically
amniocentesis you know they don't tell
you that your risk of having a placental
abruption is about one in 120.
and that we should induce you before you
have a placental abruption you know they
don't tell you the risk of preeclampsia
ending in seizure is such and such a
number you know right they they cherry
pick what's risky yep one in 1200 is the
same risk as a 25 year old having a Down
Syndrome baby how many 25 year olds
would be told that they have a risk of
having a Down Syndrome baby nobody yeah
you would never say that to a 25 year
old right right it's the same risk as
having a ruptured uterus and a bad
result as a vbac so there's a thing you
can do with numbers but it's it's really
tricky to use the term relative risk
because relative risk doesn't mean
anything unless you know what the
denominator is yeah so you need to know
what actual risk is and if you ask your
doctor who tells you it's risky or the
relative risk is twice as risky or
something like that and you ask them
what the actual risk is most of the time
they won't know
because they've been so used to talking
about relative risks that they never
bothered to actually look what the
actual risk is and this just goes
backside in a rut but it just goes back
to the power and the importance of
asking questions and feeling empowered
yourself as the as the client going into
it because a lot of times we can go to
hospitals and just suspect I'm I'm not
supposed to say anything I'm just
supposed to do whatever the doctor tells
me not realizing your own personal power
and the importance of informed consent
so ask questions and the importance of
having a relationship with a physician
that you that you feel good about right
so vbac is just a vaginal delivery the
problem is how to find a practitioner
who's supportive of it well first you
have to look at the hospital does the
hospital support it if your hospital
supports it then there's got to be
doctors there that that are supportive
of it you want to find one of those
Physicians who do it if you want to do
it at home again you've got to be able
to afford a midwife so but there's no
reason that you can't have a feedback at
home for something that's a 1 in 1200
risk of something bad happening even if
it's one in 200 risks that's a 99.5
percent chance interesting tidbit I was
one by C-section and my sister was a
vbac like I mean my my mom yeah well
that's no that's great I mean that that
and vbac used to be considered you know
yeah totally normal but again um it's
it's really a reasonable choice and
anybody who says it isn't reasonable is
not being truthful now it depends on the
scar on your uterus but most C-sections
are what's called a low transverse
cesarean section and that's a scar
that's on your uterus that that has
those risks if you have a up and down
scar what's called a classical system
that's a whole different problem and if
you've had fibroid surgery where they've
actually entered the cavity of the
uterus that's another risk factor but
we're not gonna that's something you
want to consult your physician or your
Midwife or they know all about these
sorts of things
for breach and twins it's very hard
because some states I'll make it illegal
for midwives to do it and there are many
very few doctors who will do it I would
say that probably 95 percent of breaches
are born by cesarean section when it
should be about 10 or less and with
twins I would think that it's really
it's really high in my own data we had a
98 success rate with twins with to a to
a woman who's a multi a woman who's had
a previous value of livery and a 66.7
chance in women who've had
it's their first baby with breeches we
had 100 success rate with mole tips and
80 success rate with women having their
first baby so even first baby
breach moms having 80 sex rate of
vaginal delivery which is interesting
because the chance of having a cesarean
section for any woman walking into a
hospital is higher than that yeah if you
think about it
so but finding a skilled practitioner
and one of my real pet peeves which we
didn't get into earlier
was that if you have a breech baby and
you've been going to the same OB all
along and suddenly at 38 weeks your
baby's breach and he doesn't know how to
do breach
he can be forgiven for saying that he
doesn't know how to do breach and he
should have a C-section
but I know from data and from my own
experience that more than 50 percent of
twins
will have at least one of the babies be
breached first baby second baby both
babies yeah all right at least 50 will
have at least one
being breached when a doctor finds out
that you're pregnant with twins at 12
weeks
and that doctor is not comfortable doing
a breach delivery
that doctor should tell you that I'm not
the right doctor for you you should go
find somebody else but they don't from
12 weeks they'll talk about well we'll
schedule your C-section to 37 weeks and
blah blah blah blah blah blah yeah and
that is completely unethical and that
bothers me greatly that if you know if
you're not an expert in twins
and if you don't know how to do a breach
you're not an expert in Twins then why
are you reporting yourself out there as
an expert in Twins and taking care of
twin moms during their pregnancy you
should be referring that person to
somebody who's willing to take care of
twins in labor yeah absolutely right wow
that's so so finding finding a skilled
practitioner is not a willing
practitioner is the hard part about it
and that's part of why I and my friends
Rick said David and breach Without
Borders we're going around the world and
trying to rekindle the skill the skill
so that and it's Grace nothing can be
more gratifying than when I get an email
or something from a midwife or even a
resident who's taken my course and says
Stu Dr Sue you know I I had a surprise
breach yesterday and I knew exactly what
to do and I knew exactly what I had to
do was nothing I just watched the baby
did all its Cardinal movements and
rotated and came out all by itself it's
like yeah instead of trying to push it
back up inside so that you could do an
emergency C-section on them oh this is
what happens at the hospital yeah right
wow and then you're there basically to
safeguard in case any any in case they
do need you oh a lot of times they need
some manipulation and stuff like that
but but many breaches will come out and
they'll come out and you just watch them
and they're and what's beautiful about
breech birth is that they're telling you
whether they're okay or not they're
telling you by their skin color by their
tone uh by something called capillary
filling by the cord how what does the
cord look like how they're rotating as
they're coming down and if they start to
start to look in their tone I forgot
about tone this is the most important
one of all
um they tell you that they're fine and
when they start to not be fine then when
you know you need to know the skills of
how to intervene and deliver them yeah
and if you know the skills the idea that
a baby is going to be trapped in there
or something which is this terrible
thing that we all hear about sometimes
and even a skilled practitioner that may
happen to them once or twice in a
lifetime but it's very very rare to
happen and also injuries are not
you're not injury free by doing a
C-section for a breach
a lot of breaches are injured badly at
cesarean section because the people
don't know how to do breach delivery in
a in a delivery of a breech baby at
cesarean section is still is still a
breach delivery you have to know how to
do the Maneuvers and how to get get the
arms to swept down and get the head Flex
so you can get the head to come out and
they're very simple maneuvers
and in in a two-day course I'm not
saying people are are experts in breach
delivery but every practitioner who's
out there in the world is going to at
some point find themselves with a
surprise breach
and they're not going to know what to do
and they're going to show up at the
emergency room and nobody's going to
know what to do and the likelihood that
that baby is going to have a bad outcome
is significantly increased because no
one knows what to do and all they know
what to do is to pull out a scalpel and
to do a uh to do a C-section to still
deliver the baby breach which is absurd
as can be wow that's really interesting
and all those when you're talking about
the obstetrician and interviewing and
finding the right person that also
applies to midwives too and in certain
states where it is legal because you
know you're in California where midwives
couldn't do that without a physician
certain States like here midwives are
trained and know how to deliver breach
bursts and twin bursts just fine and
again if you're planning to have lots of
children
then you want to avoid that cesarean
section you really really do yeah if
it's your only baby you're going to have
one baby and it's breached and your
doctor recommends a C-section I mean is
it the end of the world no yeah but then
you want to do things like um skin to
skin right away and maybe even vaginal
seating yeah you know what that is
you've heard of that no oh vaginal
seating is a very interesting
relatively new idea which makes perfect
sense and your microbiome guys probably
know all about this but about an hour
before you take the woman for her
C-section you take a surgical sponge you
soak it in Saline and you put it in the
woman's vagina
and you leave it there for an hour okay
and then just before you prep the
abdomen and you prep the woman for the
Cesarean section you pull the sponge out
and you put it in a sterile container
and then when you deliver the baby
you take the sponge and you wipe the
baby's nose and mouth and face
interesting with the sponge that's got
moms that soaked up Mom's microbiome for
the last hour in a sterile I mean in a
safe sponge without any uh antibiotic or
Betadine or anything like that and in
theory it makes perfect sense because
that first gut colonization in that
first respiratory tract colonization is
ultimately set you up for life and when
you you know we know that women who are
born by scheduled repeat cesarean
section where babies are not exposed to
that they have a higher rate of
childhood asthma they have a writer of
autoimmune disorders and an adult onset
diabetes as well wow probably all
related to the microbiome super
interesting we have a long way to go
still I feel like when it comes to not
to Going Back To Nature and
understanding the Simplicity of actually
how healthy and normal birth is but in
regards to ways that we can make the
hospital experience better yeah there it
is fairly obvious what we're doing wrong
yeah and it's fairly obvious what nature
design and it's brilliant to have
doctors who really care
and are able to take care of us when we
when we want to and again I want to
reiterate one more time that the doctors
and nurses are not
well they are the problem but they're
not the cause of the problem right they
they really want to do good I really do
believe it I mean there's obviously
some that are just yeah outliers yeah
yeah they're outliers that's good work
for it that are really difficult to deal
with but and that don't like their job
anymore that are unhappy in their job
and and you can and you can really see
it sometimes and one of the good clues
that I have for people that don't know
about if they move to a new community
and they're going to find like I need to
find a doctor in the community how would
I find a doctor in a new community one
of the things you can know can do when
the nurses love this is you can call
Labor and Delivery and speak to one of
the nurses in labor and delivery and ask
them if you were pregnant who would you
go to because the nurses and labor
delivery know the doctors they know
their bedside manner they know their
skill set they know they're you know
surgically good they know that some
doctors will cut episiotomies on
everybody some doctors are really
impatient other doctors are really kind
and gentle and they'll let you go a lot
longer they won't say you know if you're
pushing for two hours and your baby
isn't out we're gonna do a section
you've heard that I mean everybody hears
that yeah there's no that's another one
of those
even number rules which is stupid if
you're pushing for two hours and the
baby's fine there's no reason you can't
keep pushing if you're pushing for one
hour and the baby isn't fine then you
shouldn't keep pushing it isn't having a
number and not individualizing your care
is is wrong and the uh and and I guess
the the best way to sum up the medical
model is that it runs out an algorithm
and we as human beings are not
algorithmic we're all individuals
so informed consent being pretty much
the biggest Factor here in this
conversation part of the important
consent is just like listening to
different opinions coming here into this
conversation is there any other
recommendation you have for like my last
question for you for anyone listening
who really wants to be fully informed
before they make their sit all their
decisions yeah well the informed consent
is an is a is a quagmire it's a quandary
a little bit because because informed
consent is based on
being given
you know good information
okay well who defines what's good
information
well it's defined by the standard of
care
well who defines the standard of care
what does standard of care even mean
Center of care means what like-minded
physicians in a similar situation would
do
well that's really interesting because
if you're the only doctor doing breach
at a hospital you're you're violating
the standard of care but are you really
violating the standard of care so these
words can be manipulated and then
informed consent because can become
skewed because you're being given
information that isn't really factual
or it's
biased so it's really hard to know
when you're given informed consent
because you can't really be given
informed consent if you're not given
information from which to make consent
from it so it's you know it's a
catch-22 so to speak so if you're only
told that breach is dangerous then
you're given informed consent for a
cesarean section yeah okay I gave
informed consent but you weren't really
weren't given informed consent so again
it all boils down I believe to doing
your own homework to investigating this
thing this is such an important thing
and you may do it once two three five
times in your life and you need to put
time into it
yeah you know people go to Consumer
Reports to figure out what kind of
television set to buy
but when they're pregnant they you know
they got a Blue Cross card they pull it
out that's they go to the same guy
that's been doing their pap smear for 10
years yeah and they don't know anything
about that person's capability super
common in today's world I don't imagine
that's the people listening to this
episode right now but it's very common
for the general population
yeah so everybody listening make sure
you share this with somebody who isn't
listening because because sometimes I do
feel like we preach to the choir
because in our own podcast I know that
you know every now and then we'll have a
dissenter or somebody that won't like it
but people who people have a real
trouble listening to something that
makes them uncomfortable that's why
people who only watch Fox won't watch
MSNBC or vice versa you know that sort
of thing it makes them uncomfortable to
hear things
and so one of the that's the way we deal
with that is called cognitive dissonance
and and one of the major weapons of
cognitive dissonance is to ignore data
that doesn't agree with you
or to promote data that does or to
ridicule somebody who's so in other
words instead of debating somebody you
just say that's that like I said that's
that crazy guy who does home early I
might just have to have you on for a
debate I'll host a debate on this topic
I bet yeah we talked we talked about
that at dinner last night I would love
to do that yeah I would love to get one
of those two guys from Cornell uh Frank
chervinak or Amos Greenbaum I'll throw
their names onto them okay
um they are you know sort of anti-home
birthers they're they're so they're
self-proclaimed ethicists let me know if
you guys want to hear see this debate
yeah or even just somebody who someone
Maternal Fetal Medicine doctor who just
doesn't believe that that home birth is
a good idea or that breach birth is a
good idea
um I would love to have a conversation
because I'm sure that on some things
they're right
but
they're not right for everybody
and on some things I'm right I know that
for a fact you know it's but but I'm not
right for everybody exactly and our
model the Midwifery model understands
that you know as my friend Kimberly says
on the end of our documentary it's
called the heads up the disappearing art
of breach delivery which I say anybody's
got to breach should check that out
heads up the disappearing out of breach
delivery but she says you know home
birth breech birth may not be for
everybody but informed decision making
is for everybody
and you need to inform yourselves
because this is just such a life event
and it sets our kids up for success or
failure far more than we can even
comprehend yeah while we're doing then
because you you don't see the downstream
consequences
sometimes ever but we can see you can
see Trends and we've seen what's
happened to our health our lifespan has
been increasing up until recently when
just first dropped him for the first
time in years the last couple years
but our health has not been increasing
yeah right yeah chronic illnesses are
way up totally and I think it all begins
at Birth yeah I I agree with you I think
I think birth is such a sacred event so
important that I think a lot of women
going into their first birth might just
not really think about or consider but
the emotional impact of your birth is
powerful there I mean women listen to
this know this they have either maybe a
traumatic birth that has really affected
an impacted them in a negative way or
they've had positive births that just
bring them so much joy and all birth
stories are important they all matter
because it's such a sacred event and
everybody anybody who's witnessed a
natural birth
and I and I feel one like one of the
luckiest people on the planet because I
wouldn't thousands of them
um
I'm in awe first of all all the power of
women
secondly the what nature designed
you know you can see a woman that is
grimacing beyond belief as she's pushing
out that baby and she's been screaming
and she is been in pain and yelling at
her partner and all that stuff and then
the baby comes out and it's like
I know it's it's like wow this is great
let's do it yeah yeah that sort of thing
I mean to witness that so I feel very
very fortunate and I think for families
it's it could be bonding beyond belief
um you know if you have somebody in your
family who's a naysayer about the way
you're choosing to give birth then it's
better off then you're better off not
trying to bring them on board during
that time but for the for your children
and your immediate family to be able to
Bear witness to how nature is Nature's
design
is again like I said I feel like I'm
really really lucky I've had my ups and
downs in my career there's no question
about it
um you know it's it's affected me
physically and emotionally
um
uh just be you know being on call for as
long as I've been on call and doing
practicing the way I practice took its
toll on me and right now I'm having a
great time yeah taking a break I took a
break for a year and I've been teaching
and traveling but the it's been an honor
it's been a real honor to um to
let people have people let me in their
lives like that right yeah and I'll take
it for granted oh I agree I always say
how one day since you know this was my
last birth my fifth and like one day I'm
gonna have to become a doula or
something or a midwife because I just
love birth so much and I love being a
part of it I just think it's so sacred
and powerful and magical and amazing and
one of my favorite moments in the
hospital when I used to work in the
hospital was uh after the baby was out
the baby was on mom's chest and and uh
the nurse was just doing her thing and
stuff like that I would sit in a chair
in the corner with the chart
and I'd be writing no orders and I'd be
just watch it
and again
most people never have the opportunity
to see what I see what I saw and just to
see you know the
husband or the the partner and the woman
kissing each other and uh and the
looking at their baby and talking to
their baby the best yeah the best moment
of your life and the nurses knowing
enough to leave them alone you know
it doesn't have to be a golden hour
it could be a golden
five hours or golden 30 minutes whatever
it is but just leave them alone for a
while
just let them come down and just keep
the room silent
and just let the in the sounds of the
room it's just yeah I get I'm just very
lucky yeah amazing so thank you for
having me yeah thank you so much for
being here for this conversation I'm
sure you and I could go on and on about
this because we both clearly love birds
we will if we have dinner later yeah
yeah we both clearly love her so I
really appreciate you coming on and
continuing this conversation off camera
thanks for everyone being here listening
thank you